this is jaco podcast number 84 with echo
Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening gentlemen
your life expectancy from the day you
join your battalion will be precisely
three weeks the florid moustached major
who addressed us at the small
reinforcements camp a few miles from Bay
you obviously had misplaced had a
misplaced sense of humor or he should
have been sacked on second thought he
definitely should have been sacked not
that any of the dozen infantry
subalterns took the slightest notice of
what to us with the ramblings of an old
fool he was probably no more than 40 the
fourth Battalion the Somerset light
infantry was in 129 brigade and was a
pre-war territorial army battalion with
close links with Bristol and bath in the
United Kingdom till late June 1944 it
was a close-knit unit which had almost
been decimated within a period of 48
hours on 5th of July three officers and
62 other ranks were required as
reinforcements between the 14th and the
18th of July a further 12 officers of
whom I was one and 479 other ranks
arrived and even then the battalion was
still below its full strength of 36
officers and nearly 700 NCOs and men
this will give some idea of the
appalling level of infantry casualties
which had to be accepted in order to
enlarge the slender and vulnerable
Normandy beachhead because I had the had
had previous experience of 6 pounder
anti-tank guns the commanding officer
Limpy lieutenant-colonel CG Lipscomb
posted me as second in command to the
battalions anti-tank platoon which
consisted of six guns but my stay with
the platoon was short and I was quickly
sucked into the real infantry battle
as commander of 18 platoon in D company
on the 31st of July
immediately after the Battle of Brisco
sard d company had just lost their
commander Tim Braithwaite who lost a
foot and gained a military cross an 18
platoon there commander so that right
there is the beginning of a book that
we're gonna look at today it's called 18
platoon it's written by a guy named
Sidney Gerry Jay ary who was born in
Essex in 1924 joined the Army in 1942 as
a private soldier in 1943 he was
commissioned and from 19 from July of
1944 until June of 1945 he served as the
platoon commander for 18 Belton and the
chances of survival for an infantry
subaltern in a rifle company during the
campaign in northwest Europe were slim
most survived for only a few weeks
Sidney Geri survived 10 months from July
1944 when he took command of 18 platoon
in Normandy until the end of the war
near bremen in early May of 1945 so this
guy this is this is amazing this guy
Sidney Gerry be the only platoon
commander in the in the British Second
Army to survive as a platoon commander
from Normandy to the German surrender
one guy
one guy and this is the guy it's yeah
it's amazing and you're going to see
that his attitude is I mean the lessons
that he learned he was young coming in
was 20 years old 20 year old platoon
commander coming in in experience kind
of lived a sheltered life you got to
check out some pictures of him he has
that look - he was a sheltered look he
looks like you know sheltered it looks
like a little young whippersnapper so
we'll go back to the book here as he
breaks down what a platoon was at this
time in 1944 the war establishment of a
British infantry platoon was 36 men it
consisted of three rifle sections each
of ten men including a Bren gun er each
commanded by a corporal or sometimes a
lance sergeant there was also a small
platoon headquarters with a two inch
mortar detachment a Piatt which was a
anti-tank weapon the platoon sergeant
and the commander's Batman / runner on
July 31st 18 platoon consisted of 17 all
ranks 12 of whom were recent
reinforcements Hill 112 and brick
wrister guard had claimed the rest so
think about that you're supposed to have
36 people in your platoon and they have
17 of which 12 are replacements which
means that 29 people had been casualties
there's seven people that had been
either killed or wounded they're sorry
seven people out of this 36 that hadn't
been killed or wounded that remained in
the platoon right now so that's what
we're talking about here and again he's
come in no combat experience he rolls in
and going back to the book I sensed
instantly that a tight grip was required
particularly so because those few who
survived Hill 112 had witnessed what was
without a doubt the most horrific
tragedy that befell the battalion during
the entire case
Payne so he's about to explain what they
had been through he wasn't there for it
but he knew and he had heard what they
had been through and I'm gonna say that
again this is the most horrific tragedy
for the entire campaign this is what
they're coming off of him this is who
he's going to take over for because what
they had been through back to the book
during a nut during a company night
attack one of our soldiers had been hit
in the lower chest by a rifle or
machine-gun bullet passing through his
body it had not killed him outright the
bullets devilish coarse lay through the
soldier's webbing equipment pouch which
contained a 77 phosphorus smoke grenade
which exploded caught on barbed wire the
poor soldier laid disemboweled for all
around to see his writhing body a
smoking mass of burning phosphorus
responding to his agonized screams to
put him out of his misery his platoon
commander shot him through the heart and
finally through the head after the poor
man's final frenzied please not there
sir through the head Doug Proctor was
witness to this sublimely courageous
incident which seared itself upon all
our hearts so that's what you're going
to take over for okay can you do that I
mean is that like legal you know like if
they found out that that happen I have
no idea what the legal ramifications are
but the moral weight on the shoulders of
the men that witness that is is
unbelievably it's hard to imagine what
that feels like
back to the book to the NCOs sergeant
Jim Kingston and corporal Doug Proctor
immediately reported to me and explained
forcefully and in great detail the poor
state of the platoon as they knew it to
be so you've got these guys these are
the senior enlisted guys in the platoon
Jim Kingston and Doug Proctor you hear a
lot about them and they're coming from
here's this new guy checking in and
they're coming to him and they're you
know telling him how what what a bad
state the platoon is in back to the book
while they did so I was conscious of
being weighed up was I fit to be their
platoon commander they were responsible
anxious and discriminating NCOs
that stands for noncommissioned officer
to the senior enlisted guys and my
apprenticeship was to start immediately
they were startled by my attire
previously warned by a young officer
who'd fought in Tunisia that battle
dress was most unsuitable for brat
battle I had come prepared in sand
colored corduroy trousers and a stout
pullover not unlike that now worn
throughout the army among my prejudices
was an acute dislike of steel helmets
they gave me headaches on exercises in
England I had been obliged to wear one
but the surge of individualism which now
engulfed me convinced me that this was
an article of equipment best left out of
battle so he's he shows up and he's kind
of dressed out of uniform doesn't want
to wear his helmet wearing corduroy
pants back to the book battle schools in
England had insisted that off infantry
officers should wear the same equipment
and dress as their soldiers the idea
being that they could not be then be so
easily identified by enemy snipers they
also decreed that one should carry a
rifle or a Sten gun clearly this was
ridiculous how on earth could your own
soldiers recognize you in the heat of
battle if you went through such lengths
to disguise he had the same the same
attitude as Lieutenant lean Korea that
was wearing the orange vest you remember
that so he could be identified in battle
by his own men that's what this guy's
attitude is like I'm not going to dress
like I would also need to be they need
to know who
that I'm out there how could they need
to be able to see me back to look I
dispensed with the rifle and gun -
because I'm hopelessly short-sighted and
I did not fancy trying to command a
platoon while got up like a Christmas
tree
meaning covered in a bunch of gear as a
concession to impending battle I sported
a 45 colt automatic pistol with two
spare magazines the 38 Enfield revolver
then general issue throughout the army
managed to combine total mechanical
liability with complete ineffectiveness
I once fired six shots from one at a
target pinned to a plywood board
none of which even penetrated the board
neither did I hit the target which gave
me little confidence in this weapon the
nine pounds I paid for the colt proved a
sound investment so there's a lot of
people that like to talk about what type
of sidearm there you've got a big
proponent for the Colt 45 the old
classic again important to remember that
he's not even carrying a rifle because
he knows his job asleep nicely when we
had to seal seal leaders that would
spend too much time on their gun I would
say hey you know what they used to care
in the Marine Corps in the army if you
were leader you know they'd carry they
carry a pistol so give me a rifle and we
take it from like you you need to be
leading not shooting life talks about
that a lot oh yeah it's very you know
life talks about his mentality which was
he wants to shoot yeah he's from Texas
you know he wants to shoot his gun and
he realized hey I'm not here to shoot my
gun I'm here to you know be a high port
and be off my gun and leading that's my
job
and these guys took it to the point
where they're not even carrying a rifle
now he's talking about his senior
leadership a little bit his enlisted
leadership back to the book Jim Kingston
was short quiet and shy with the
shrewdness of a countrymen although he
had lived and worked in Bristol all his
life he barely raised his voice but had
total command over his section there was
no argument with Jim but that's another
thing to fight about this book this book
it
takes so many stereotypes from from
Sidney Gerry on down like the
stereotypes are just out the window of
the way this platoon was and there's a
classic example you know you picture the
senior enlisted guy this bra
you know Gunny Highway scenario not
happening hmm
now he now he talks about Doug Proctor
back to the book Doug prop Proctor
although a Somerset came from nodding
him also short he was positive direct
with unfailing common sense and like Jim
quietly dominated his section so there's
another and I got to see some great
leaders there are some guys that were in
learning to you bruiser that were quiet
when they were into you bruiser and when
I was putting them through their next
workup
I was thinking myself hey they're gonna
be able to step up the lead and that's
exactly how they did it right there they
were just like quiet professional and
controlling but they'd run their mouth
to get it done
back to the book I had not previously
met any platoon like this one they were
quiet thoughtful and on abrasive
soldiers there was little swearing and
there existed a tranquility in their
relationships with one another their
eyes implored me not to fail them two
factors were immediately apparent
firstly the platoon required quiet thumb
and confident leadership so that's a
good assessment you know you can see
these guys don't need anybody yelling at
them and here's the second point
secondly if I failed to use my
imagination and slavish ly followed the
battle school drills most of the platoon
would not survive another major battle
so all the things he learned the
standards typical stuff that he'd
learned that wasn't gonna work and it
hadn't worked that's what I had so many
replacements come in back to the book in
fact the problem that faced me with 18
platoon was identical to the one facing
general Montgomery our Army Group
commander how to fight and defeat the
cream of the SS Panzer divisions in the
close norman normandy bocaj and still
retained sufficient infantry
riflemen to live and fight tomorrow the
problem was a difficult one obviously I
must set an example and always lead from
the front however if I became overeager
and got myself killed or wounded the
whole object of my previous training and
my responsibilities to my platoon would
be cast away I would in fact be letting
down 18 platoon so he knows he's got to
lead from the front same time he knows
gonna stay alive hmm he knows got to
stay alive and this Normandy fighting
here he talks about Normandy being a
defenders paradise meaning when you're
on the defense and Normandy it's good
it's a paradise for the people on
defence which was the Germans back to
the book we fought from one hedgerow to
the next up torturous overgrown sunken
lanes ideal country for the German
defender but appalling for attacking
infantry however no arm but infantry
could take and hold the Normandy Bocage
bocaj is like a trees shrubs mangled
together it was here that I served my
apprenticeship and the platoon developed
its character which despite constant
depletion by casualties over the coming
10 months it would retain until the end
of the war it was also here that
imperceptibly I became possessive with
18 platoon it was mine to be guarded
with an almost maternal jealousy that
resented all criticism of my soldiers
that's building at this point most
important it was in the Bocage that I
began to appreciate how vital is grip
grip on oneself grip on one soldiers and
grip on the situation unlike characters
and novels and films most men react
nervously to real battle conditions
discipline and regimental pride are
supports but in decisive moments of
great danger the grip of the leader
on the lead is paramount infantry
section platoon commanders must possess
the minds and hearts of their soldiers
strength of character is not enough
successful leadership in battle although
complex and intangible always seem to
need to depend on two factors firstly
soldiers must have confidence in their
leaders professional ability and
secondly they must trust them as men so
there you go they gotta have confidence
in your ability and Trust and this trust
topic comes up all the time and I use
the word relationships kind of
interchangeably with trust I always have
to remind myself to point that out that
when I'm talking about relationships and
building relationships in business on
the battlefield in life relationships
are trust that's what they are yeah they
build your relationship on trust and I
guess you could have you know
relationships that aren't built on trust
that those are like another thing you
know I have a relationship with that guy
but you know yeah so but that's not
that's not one thought I'm already I'm a
good relationships yeah those are based
on trust and there's obviously the
second most important thing to him so
first is confidence in their ability and
second is trust I like this part it
helps to if a leader has the reputation
of being lucky Field Marshal Montgomery
placed great importance on the principle
of making the enemy dance to your tune
nowhere is this more important than in
platoon and company battle it is
decisive because if you do not dominate
events your enemy will there you go
that's jiu-jitsu right there be first
fever yeah you've got to be first you
got to dictate the pace you got a you
got to be proactive back to the books
sound leadership like true love to which
I suspect is closely related is all
powerful it can overcome the seemingly
impossible
its effect on both leader and lead is
profound and lasting even after the
passage of 40 years brief mention of the
battalions finest officers and NCOs
bring brings a smile to the faces of the
survivors of my platoon their resentment
of those who failed to lead when it
mattered most still runs astonishingly
deep so leadership can overcome
seemingly impossible this is why
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield now he's going into
his so that's kind of his assessment and
this is based on his experience which
we're about to get into then he does
more assessments there's more he talks
more about what he learns about
leadership as a whole but you have to
kind of understand what he went through
and figure out where he learned it from
the first his first command in battle
here we go back to the book we were to
attack this rugged hill from the West
with the 5th Wiltshire's on our right
and the 4th Wiltshire's in reserves the
approach march to our forming up place
had been a nightmare of swirling
abrasive dust shelling and the stench of
exhaust fumes from the tanks which
transported us forward we were due to
attack at 1500 hours with a company
leading on the right and B company on
the left we followed B Company B Company
moved off quickly with our company
deployed about 300 yards behind their
forward platoons had barely crossed the
stream when concentrated spandau fire
came from the front and from both flanks
so spend now fire this is kind of a
generic term that the Brits used for
German machine guns they're primarily
talking about the mg42 which is a big
belt-fed machine gun very similar to a
modern what we have m60 or mark 48
machine gun a big heavy belt belt fed
machine gun which lays down the insane
amounts of suppressive fire so here we
go they're getting hit from both flanks
from with these machine guns back to the
book there must
been about 12 machineguns firing at one
time this devastating display of
firepower stopped the battalion dead in
its tracks
there was no way forward or around it
and no way to retire some of the guns
had engaged D company over the heads of
B company and private Morrison 18
platoon was killed so there's his first
guy lost I like this the way he starts
off this next sentence here first word
powerless so he's in his first combat
situations got one man killed and how
does he feel powerless here we go
powerless and crouching in a hedgerow I
tried to identify the spandau positions
this proved impossible as they still
kept up their crushing display of
firepower in my ignorance I expected
that the enemy machine gunners would
soon expend their ammunition they did
not nor did they in dozens of subsequent
battles so he's waiting for them to stop
shooting they don't it just keeps coming
captain's camel commanding a company was
severely wounded major Thomas commanding
D Company was killed their companies
were badly cut up on our right v
Wiltshire's had fared no better with
their co killed and casualties mounting
their attack also foundered as the
afternoon turned to evening shelling and
mortaring increased much of it passing
over our heads thus isolating us from
the reserve battalion so that the
Germans are more during over their head
so at the reserve battalion can't get to
him shortly before dark a troop of tanks
arrived one of which was able to cross
the stream and give us some brave close
support undoubtedly it increased our
morale but it was not enough to get the
whole attack underway again any movement
by B Company to our front brought down
instant and concentrated spandau fire
the same applied to us a few hundred
yards to their rear fortunately the
enemy did not seem to have any anti-tank
guns
so our armoured friends were
parrot of ly safe but the fact remained
that about 12 span doze had halted a
battalion attack without our locating
even one of them
that's what suppressive fire does that's
what that's what a big machine gun does
you got 12 big machine guns they're
stopping 700 people from moving
that's called suppressive fire that's
why you know you heard Roger Hayden talk
about how how many heavy weapons they
how many machine guns they'd carry they
had I think they had nine out of over to
the 14 that's why yeah as dusk fell a
new plan was made
C&D companies would advance in single
file through a and B companies and using
the cover of dark darkness infiltrate
the enemy position once through them we
would climb to the top of the hill and
consolidate a cold and damp mist
descended which with fading light gave
us welcome cover but also wretched
discomfort we were still in shirtsleeves
which became damp from the sweat of our
exertion climbing the steep lower slopes
alert which pistol in hand I anticipated
a sudden brush with an enemy post not a
shot was fired by some miracle we passed
right through their positions without
being too decked detected our luck had
changed so you're going to see quite a
bit of that is as they what the Germans
were doing at this point defending hard
but then instead of staying and dying in
most cases they would retreat and so
they fight really hard for a while and
then retreat Advaita advance if they had
a opportunity but you're going to see a
lot of that back to the book we now had
to advance across a large orchard so I
deployed the platoon with two sections
up and urged them forward as fast as
possible suddenly in the middle of the
orchard we came across a young girl in a
clean white dress sitting with her back
to an apple tree sketching now I just
talked about this the muster of the
random things that happen in combat and
this is what I'm talking about and how
do you train for that how would you ever
if you're running a battle problem to
train people what are you going to do
put a white grow on a white dress and
then sitting with a back to a tree
sketching doesn't make any sense how do
you deal with it back
book she seemed quite oblivious to the
border fire in 18 platoons warlike
appearance how to stop pretty young
girls from interfering with battle had
not been part of my training as an
officer cadet nor had it appeared on the
curriculum of any battle schools which
without exception had despaired of my
future as an infantry soldier
fortunately there was a farmhouse beside
the orchard and it had a cellar where
she was persuaded to shelter while we
got on with our battle I reported what
had occurred to our company commander
who told me that I was being quite
ridiculous really Jerry you're being
absurd with that remark I realized that
he had been a schoolmaster a breed with
whom I had been in conflict until quite
recently a breed with whom I'd been in
conflict with until quite recently so
this guy has the the attitude of a
schoolmaster which in England is a
little bit different and especially in
the 1930s and 40s you know the strict I
think of a Pink Floyd you know the
headmaster how can you have any pudding
if you don't eat your meat that guy
that's what he's comparing them to his
next sarcastic remark I would be obliged
Jerry if you would kindly get on with
the war he gave me a little indication
of what he wanted my platoon to do nor
did it inspire confidence we were still
over 200 yards from the meadow
surrounded by cornfields which was the
company's objective it now became
apparent that our company commander had
an academic and detached attitude of
mind which made it quite impossible for
him to command the company so the
company the company commanders on the
game there's one thing to be detached
from your emotions to make sure you're
not getting caught up and mayhem there's
another thing to be so detached that
you're not even aware of what's going on
and actually I had a name for this when
I was running training battlefield
aloofness is what I called it because we
get these guys you get these guys and
we'd be running these crazy battlefield
problems on them and there'd be not to
be crazy and you'd go I remember one
time there's a the task unit commander
there's always mayhem going on the
platoons are getting overrun and people
are getting you know shot with paintball
and they're not hitting their objectives
and I walk over to
complicated he's sitting in a Humvee our
sorry the the tu commander the troop
commander he's sitting in a Humvee and I
like the windows up because they're both
windows but he's gonna get shot with
paintball the windows up he's just
sitting in there he's got his headset on
others radio like a knock on the door
I'm like hey man you know what's going
on out there he said well I'm trying to
gather that information right now and
I'm like bro you're gonna gather
anything here but dust yeah you need to
get out there and make something happen
because his idea was you know I need to
be detached yeah which I talked about
being - that's all the time but there's
a difference between being and as you
see the same thing in businesses where
the the the boss or the leader has no
idea what's happening on the ground
floor right he doesn't know what the the
workers are doing so he's so far
detached that he's he's you know let
them eat cake right right that's where
that's where this guy is wait so why is
that it's because what they they just in
a way just depend on them to just handle
it on their own
thanks for gonna handle it on their own
which is a good attitude to have until
they can't handle it anymore right right
once they can't once a once a team or a
platoon or a business unit can't handle
it on their own and they're failing you
have to get you have to go do your job
you have to step up you have to step
down
you have leader you have to get in there
and is where that stuff away yeah yeah
so it's that without the get in there
part right it's just like I did it call
me when it's done yeah and and the
problem is somebody's gotta sort these
problems out yeah yeah they're there
they're real and and they're not getting
better and you might take you a minute
to go okay wait a second these problems
aren't getting better what should I do
once you realize that they're not
getting better you got to get in there
make it happen yeah this guy's not doing
that back to the book he'd be behaved
like a supercilious umpire on an
exercise in England at any moment I
expected him to admonish me for bad
tactics and the schoolboy and me feared
that I might be sent to the headmaster
for a beating so they continue on when
he's the highest point which face the
enemy and the other platoons quickly
deployed to give all around offense of
the other flanks after being more gird
the company required no
courage meant to dig in it's a real
motivator getting mortared will make you
shovel hard yes the company commander
walked round the platoon positions
eyeing everyone with distaste nothing
pleased him
and he suddenly announced that he must
sleep which he did in my slit trench
getting not a good feeling about this
company commander just looking at
everyone like negatively and then all of
a sudden he wants to sleep I like this
guy and of course he sleeps in in my
trench yeah now this is good there's
another officer that's there that's
present a guardian angel was watching
over us in the guise of Dennis Clark
Dennis some years older than me was
exceptionally kind to me and tolerant of
my immaturity pay attention this is good
he took my took me by the arm a few
paces away from my platoon who the hell
is in command of this shambles sunny I
muttered the unconvincing explanation
that it was our company commander
looking me straight in the eye he drew a
deep breath which managed to express
both exasperation have my explanation
and sympathy with my predicament you and
I know that he is not so what are you
going to do about it I asked him if I
should take command
his expression hardened yes you bloody
well should some demonstration of
loyalty to my wretched company commander
was obviously required I blurted out
that he was really a schoolmaster and
not a professional soldier so it's kind
of defending him Dennis put his arm
around my shoulder and whispered in my
ear so was I sunny so that's awesome the
company commander is not leading and
this this guy Dennis Clark I think he's
a artillery gunner pulls this guy's head
aside and just bro you better take
charge of this and you better do it
quick back to the book we were now well
dug in on
objective the company commander was
still asleep Denis was arranging
defensive fire tasks for me I had
assumed command of D company without a
word passing between our company
commander and me in practice it made not
the slightest difference because because
like a bad preparatory school master he
saw his role as one of examination and
criticism this he continued to do
despite the incredulous stairs of the
NCOs
so he's taking charge and and he hasn't
even said anything he just done it he
just took charge and all the guy the
guys continued to walk around did stare
glare at everyone but that doesn't
matter so this is a classic example your
leaders not leading I I've given this
answer so many times but this is a
classic this might be one of the best
examples your leaders not leading that's
fine good step up and lead yourself back
to the book by dawn the enemy had
retired and elements of the Italian
moved forward to consolidate and
strengthened D company's position the
whole operation was very amateur there
was no doubt that the new company
commander could not command a company in
battle nor could I who is just beginning
to master the rudiments of commanding a
platoon he was removed within a few
hours I think Denis had something to do
with it but he was not the kind of man
to confide in
twenty-year-old subalterns so that's
another classic thing right there is
that this guy Denis who is another
officer probably went and said get this
guy out of here get this company
commander out of here but when he does
it the company commander gets removed
and and he doesn't say anything to
Sidney Gerry he doesn't you know rat it
out or brag about or make a big deal
he doesn't say anything just happens
it's like when I had a mutiny in my
platoon and the commanding officers like
no we're not firing anyone you guys get
out of here to shut your mouths and go
back to work we're like ok and then a
few days like a week later he got fired
but it wasn't because of us as far as we
know right no one's anything we just
knew he got fired yeah what reason hmm
Thanks we had something to do with it
but it same thing so you don't need to
you create distrust and disloyalty and
and not even just those words but you
don't need to create drama yeah right
don't create the drama yeah that guy's
going to consumers getting billed in
somewhere else hey you guys want
everybody yeah yeah we're not doing that
yeah we're not doing that when I'm
building up our own ego yeah by
disparaging someone else's let's worry
about the whole team yeah sound sounds
like a good idea to me you know back to
the book I now have little doubt that
for the first two months in Normandy we
lack two things comprehensive and
imaginative training and personal
experience of battle we're also
seriously handicapped by our casual
attitude to many junior officers did not
think for themselves
and persistently relied on the narrow
teaching of battle schools whose Dogma
had assumed the proportion of Holy Writ
so whatever he was taught he was taught
that's the only way you can ever do it
and these guys let's talk about this
many times on them on the podcast the
goal when I was running training was to
actually get the people to think it
wasn't good sure you have to establish
the baseline standard operating
procedures that's great and those need
to be rock-solid but once those things
are established you need to make people
understand that you don't always follow
them and you need to call off a piece of
that standard operating procedure to
insert some other thing and bring in
another percenter operating procedure
and mix and match them so you get
something that's effective you need to
think that's what a leader needs to do
and leader needs to think back to the
book the British infantry platoons and
companies were over trained and bored
stiff with basic infantry tactics which
as far as they went we're good
much of this training unfortunately had
been in the hands of battle school
instructors who themselves lacked battle
experience and imagination these tend to
become pedagogues disciples of DS
directing staff solution about which no
argument could be tolerated so DS's that
we he mentions in a bunch like that's
their solution the directing staff you
can argue with them they're the stairs
of cadre yes
yeah possibly like most of our entry
infantry they suffered some consequences
of the pre-war shortage of creativity
intelligent regimental officers too few
of them were professionally dedicated to
the extent that they could visualize how
battles will be fought and identify the
problems that might arise when planning
them they seemed to lack the capacity to
think relentlessly through these things
until solutions were found much of their
time had been spent policing the British
Empire also unlike the Germans we
British instinctively avoid displays of
keenness the enthusiasts particularly if
he is innovative is an embarrassment
thus the battlefield became our teacher
and inevitably it exacta dag rim price
in blood and time so as you're training
you've got to push yourself hard you've
got to put yourself in situations I
don't care what you're training for I
don't care if you're training for combat
in a seal platoon in an army infantry
platoon or if you're in the business
world and you're training your leaders
to handle situations or you're training
your customer service reps to handle
situations what no matter which one of
those you're in you need to push people
hard you need to put them in worst case
scenario so that they need to learn how
they need to learn how to think to get
out of those problems I recall with
embarrassment an incident at 45th
Infantry Division abadan school during
the spring of 1944 an exceptionally tall
and good-natured Canadian officer had
been sent to the school to give a talk
on the street fighting he had
experienced in Italy it was an
interesting talk but some of his advice
ran contrary to that being taught in the
school when the lecture was over the
chief instructor with insulting
condensation thanked this shy and kindly
man for a vivid word picture and turning
to the students warned us that at as
this officers experience was probably
unusual we had best not stray from the
Diaz
solution has taught at that school so
you've got a combat veteran coming back
with experience from street fighting in
Italy and he'd come back with some
different tactics and they tell them
that you don't listen that guy that's
just a rare case mm-hmm closed mind will
get you killed this is starting to talk
about their overall sort of formulation
of combat plans and how they operate it
back to the book the most successful
actions by 1815 were fought without the
support of artillery or armor we had
learned in a hard school how to skirmish
infiltrate and edge our way forward the
right or left flanking platoon attack so
beloved of the battle school staff would
rarely succeed in the Normandy bocaj I
remember with horror being locked into
timetables of meticulously planned
larged
battles these invariably left the junior
infantry commander no scope for
exploitation if you found a gap in the
enemy defenses adherence to artillery
program which rarely could be altered
effectively stopped any personal
initiative so what that's saying is you
have these the artillery that's going to
drop bombs they're going to bomb or
strike with artillery at certain regions
and certain times so you might see the
enemy running away and you have a chance
to gain a superior tactical position but
you can't because you know that that's
where the bombs are good that's where
the artillery is can be hitting in the
next 12 minutes so you can't go so now
you sit and wait so yet locked in by
that back to the book to me the
preparations for these battles assume
the demented proportion of a Kafka like
nightmare ballet in which the anonymous
they ordained that we must perform a
choreographed
ritual dance McCobb I felt trapped and
helpless no solo parts were written into
the score nor was there scope for small
groups of performers in this mammoth
ballet of machines undoubtedly far
shadows from the soul at the Battle of
Somme
and my emotions but instinct told me
that this kind of show would be unlikely
to succeed the irony was that this
support was planned and given to the
infantry with the best of intentions the
psalm had cast its shadows on our
artillery and armored commanders both
genuinely believed that their hands they
that in their hands they had the Panthea
which would protect us
the infantry from the terrible slaughter
of 1916 instead they put us in a
straitjacket so very interesting
viewpoint and and it's something that we
need to pay attention to because you've
got to be flexible you got to be
flexible and that's exactly what about
and these they would make these plans
that were so comprehensive and there was
no you weren't allowed to deviate from
the plans and when you're not allowed to
deviate from the plans and something
starts going differently than what you
expected you're trapped
yeah tough form back to the book far too
much time had been spent fitting the
infantry and armor junior leaders into
the big picture and too little time
spent training them and stimulating
their imagination initiative and
individual resourcefulness to probe draw
conclusions infiltrate and exploit
weakness in the enemy's dispositions so
he's he's criticizing this lack of
initiative lack of creativity and the
training to get that initiative
creativity back to the book after the
1st of August 18 platoon never failed in
any attack sometimes we took a little
longer than planned but we always got
there in the end
in defense we never lost one yard of
ground nor did the enemy ever penetrate
our platoon position and we always
dominated no-man's land with our patrols
whether persistent patrolling is always
sound policy I will argue elsewhere so
he's saying once he kind of figured it
out they didn't lose any more they
didn't lose any attacks and they didn't
give up any ground talks about the armor
our armor was accused of being tiger shy
meaning scare
the tiger tanks and the Germans and I
don't wonder why the devastation caused
by a single hit of an a millimeter
armor-piercing shell needed to be seen
to be believed
and this is an overall statement for the
infantry and armor the British Second
Army the sheer ferocity of the fighting
in Normandy came as a solitary cell
Ettore shock for which they were in some
ways unprepared so it was devastating
for these guys and now we start pushing
out out of outer Normandy and pushing
into the CN and here we go they're
pushing in the next day 28 August D
company occupied a Hera Court this is
the only operation of war that I ever
known to go precisely as planned our
supporting Field Regiment softened up
the objective with their 25 pounders
the company advanced over open farmland
in immaculate formation and consolidated
exactly on time the only thing lacking
was an enemy total bag one dazed German
one dead German and one dead hare rabbit
room so the only one that ever went well
was when there was no enemy to fight
against
there was two Germans one of them was
dead the other was dazed and that was
there the last battle in France
back to the book experience in Normandy
had removed anxieties regarding
commanding and under-strength platoon so
he hasn't had enough men he's supposed
to have 36 he's had like 17 18 19 in the
attack particularly at night a platoon
at full strength is just too big to
maneuver quickly three rifle sections of
about 20 above about seven men each plus
headquarters was ideal in defense it was
a different matter the more riflemen on
the ground the better or short stay in
the menzel Milan gave me time to think
the first opportunity to do so since I
took command of 18 platoon it also gave
me time to meet and talk with other
young officers in the battalion it was
then that I realized that 18 platoon was
no ordinary platoon it had some
undefinable magic no quarrels little
swearing despite the war that was the
despite the war there was something
peaceful about it a helping hand was
always available for anybody the
emotional links were firm and true I was
a happy man so he realizes once he
starts talking the other platoon
commanders he's got this really special
platoon that gets along great and he's
he realizes it doctor look no young
officer can command a platoon in battle
on his own
in Normandy I'd seen platoon commanders
served by poor NCOs struggling to gain
some semblance of control over their
bewildered and frightened men I had also
seen platoons with good NCOs go to
pieces in the hands of an indifferent
officer Jim Kingston Doug Proctor and
Owen Cheeseman set the standard and tone
for 18 platoon without them I as a
platoon commander would have joined the
ranks of so many poor young officers who
never achieved grip now going to another
he's putting together another plan as
they're advancing and obviously this is
a long book I'm doing an abridged
version hitting some highlights you
should get the book I obviously get the
book by the book back to the book at
zero four hundred hours on 24th of
September Douglas this is the new
company commander Douglas Douglas held a
long oh group by candlelight in the
cellar of the farmhouse at which much to
his annoyance I kept falling asleep we
were ordered to advance straight
eastward down a narrow country lane from
the orchard to the
main road and consolidate after the Oh
group and Oh group is what they call
like when they're when their officers
get together and pass the word they
called Oh group after the Oh group I
made myself unpopular by asking why
we're advancing towards an area of
considerable German opposition when my
patrol had found a better route by which
we might outflank the enemy so the so
he's saying hey wait why because that
his patrol his platoon had been out on a
patrol and found a better route and he's
asking why and he kind of gets shut down
I was just 20 years old at the time and
even then I knew I was incapable of
disputing orders without giving offence
we started at zero six hundred hours two
platoons leading on either side of the
track the third falling in single file
down the track itself on either side
were the small Holdings were small
holdings a few allotments and bungalows
surrounded by small picket fences the
platoons advanced through the gardens
and vegetable patches and passed on
either side of the bungalows the rear
section searching each one quickly and
while they're searching these little
bungalows as they're on patrol they find
this back to the book during one of
these hurried searches one section found
a Dutch family the windage 'as father
mother son and daughter riddled by
Schmeisser fire that's a German
machine-gun they lay in awkward postures
of death amid their ransacked home a
visit from the SS no tears came nor did
they come a half an hour later when we
came upon the charred wreckage of an
American Dakota it had carried us
parachute troops of the 82nd Airborne
Division and their torn and burnt bodies
littered the orchard like charred and
mutilated rag dolls there was a further
iron or irony attached to the front
window in what remained of the dacotahs
cockpit was a tiny teddy bear untouched
by flames two months before a lonely
teddy bear and an impersonal pool of
blood had brought forth tears
now I was collected an objective when
faced with in the span of 30 minutes
with an atrocious murder and mass
carnage by fire and he's referring there
in the beginning of the book one of his
first experiences he's by a slit trench
and there's a dead guy soldier in it and
there's a little teddy bear and and for
some reason you know he's young he's
inexperienced and it gets gets makes him
super emotional he starts crying and and
now he's a little further in the war he
sees you know this horrible murdered
family and these tragically you know
burned and killed paratroopers and he's
able to detach emotionally from it back
to the book the enemy decided to make
life unpleasant for us as possible by
sudden unpredictable concentrations of
heavy artillery right in the middle of
our company area we called them stalks
so he's going to use that word it just
means we're getting bombed one of these
shells unfortunately fell right into one
of 16 platoon slit trenches no trace
remained of the two men that were
manning in it manning a Bren in my
platoon Lance Corporal Jack Lee and
private Peter filmer were buried in the
trench they shared other members of
their section quickly dug them out
unharmed very dirty and remarkably
cheerful the self-propelled guns
increased their activities filling the
sky above the company with ugly black
airbursts they could place these with
uncanny accuracy to burst about 25 feet
above the road junction outside company
headquarters the casualties mounted
company sergeant major
Sammy Jones and spot Martin the jeep
driver were both hit outside company HQ
it was Sammy Jones who committed the
battalions only atrocity late one summer
evening as the shadows from high trees
and hedges fell across a small
I'll seal the Normandy we took some
young Waffen soul Waffen SS soldiers
prisoner one of them a short stocky and
fair youth of about 18 proved
insultingly truculent seizing the young
lout by the scruff of his neck
Samri roared you can take that Glynn out
of your eyes my boy and putting the
wretched youth across his knees he gave
his backside a sound whacking that is
legit and that's again you know Sidney
Gerry and he talks about how proud he is
that his men his men's behavior is so
upstanding throughout this whole
miserable experience and even when they
see atrocities committed like by the SS
they still maintain their discipline and
their character and this is this is what
he does Oh your little punk kid I'm
gonna spank you you know tough little SS
soldier getting put over the knee and
spanked so after the attack so now that
this is again this is happening after
one of these attacks and and the whole
the whole basic premise of this book is
attack rest attack rest attack rest so
as I'm reading them kind of picking out
some of the attacks that they're going
on and they're just moving through
France and then through Germany that's
what it is I should have explained that
earlier but this is after one of the
attacks it's interesting he says this
smiling face is vanished and the gray
look returned once more men walked with
one err cocked in the air for
approaching shells and with a slight
stoop if you remember I was talking on
JP I was talking about how like you see
guys they have the magical little
student yeah yeah that's what he's
talking about and JP didn't have those
do they fuse day enough like you stupid
he was not yeah you stupas you stand
ready to get some but these guys as and
it's contrasted because when they're on
the attack
they go into like JP mode they're
standing I'm straight they're ready to
get some but then once they're on the
defense and they're just waiting it's
shelled they start to stoop they started
to crouch a little bit he continues back
to the book the jokes began to peter out
and the cheerful good morning sir ceased
when i went around the platoons that
stand to morale was always hired during
an attack sitting around and being
shelled is not an occupation to be
recommended so there's a good lesson
there if you or your team is being
defensive about things your morale is
gonna go down mmm but you're waiting to
get hit so go out and hit somebody you
know go on the attack don't wait around
don't let your morale drown here's
another attack
back to the book scrambling out of the
culvert we set a fast pace up the side
of the road to a company's positions
this immediately brought small-arms fire
down on us but by then we were then 200
yards of their slit trenches so on we
ran as fast as we could
being soaked I began to steam my boots
squelched and seemed to drag me back
clawing at my feet as in a bad dream and
stopping me from reaching the inviting
cover of the slit trenches a company was
dug in with two platoons forwarded an
orchard face to face the enemy who were
in dikes only a few yards beyond the
third platoon was to the right rear
protecting the open flank and company
headquarters to the left rear centered
on some farm buildings it was to these
farm buildings that we ran hurling
ourselves onto the straw on the barn
floor we lay panting and gasping for
breath John a [__] a company commander
appeared round the door of the barn
he looked Haggard and worn I doubt he
had slept for a week the whole company
area was covered by the most intense
Spandau fire and defensive and the
defensive battle here was one of fire
supremacy which the Germans had
undoubted
one a company's morale was low they had
just lost Harry Barnes one of the
platoon commanders who refusing to take
cover strutted about in his usual manner
he took a complete burst of Spandau fire
under the arm
Harry was an amazing and fearless fellow
who didn't care a damn for anything even
after the burst hit him he still lived
for about three hours the men respected
Harry and with their idle shot down in
front of them they were very jumpy
another time you have to watch out for
morale obviously now if you remember
this book started in the summertime and
now we're starting to get towards fall
and this this was something I'd never
thought about before when fall comes you
know the Sun is up for a shorter period
of time there here we go back to the
book the nights became longer and the
dawn's gray and chilly the sunsets were
red and vivid and the days though
beautiful shortened rapidly as the
nights lengthened the hours of stag
lengthened and with them the mental and
physical fatigue of the company so they
have to stay after stay up you know
rotate through watches at night you just
don't get to sleep the whole time so if
it's dark for longer you got to stay
awake longer at night so that's starting
to wear on the company itself back to
the book there was there is one incident
small room when remembered by itself in
a life of such incidents but very but to
me very vivid in my platoon there was a
young lad aged 18 named Biddle he was of
slight of build fare and looked a mere
child he had a pleasant personality and
was liked by everyone he had joined the
company ATLA Menzel Malone after we had
crossed the CN
at Vernon in August one morning there
was a crack in a short interval of
silence soon the shout went out
stretcher bearers echoed through the
orchard I ran towards the commotion and
saw Biddle writhing in agony on the
ground at first he looked unhurt but as
I tore open his tunic I saw a clear
wound through his abdomen coming out by
his spine he soon became numb and was no
longer in pain but was very frightened
and shivered we dragged him back behind
the house and applied field dressings to
his stomach and his back in case the
wound started to bleed his young life
slowly ebbing from his body our
stretcher bearers quietly and reverently
carried him away the scene is now too
poignant to remember without shedding a
tear after Biddle had been evacuated the
morale of the platoon dropped he had
been hit while standing in his slit
trench by a sniper at least 300 yards
away
[Music]
and you know it's interesting and I
didn't go into this part but there's a
part earlier in the book where he he
basically disparages somewhat the use of
snipers hmm and he talks about how they
usually don't gain you anything
tactically but it's interesting what it
does to the morale of a platoon isn't it
and he you know he doesn't complete he
explains that there's uses and there's
ever believed me there's probably no
bigger believer in the use of snipers in
the world than me but it's interesting
yeah he he basically you can tell he's a
very a guy with you know this extremely
high moral character and he kind of gets
the feeling when he explains it that you
know he didn't feel comfortable with
sniping because people aren't expecting
it there's not a battle happening he
felt like it was a cheap shot mm-hmm
just but it's interesting the effect
that it actually has on his platoon in
this moment here we're going to get to a
point he's got Germans are in a dike of
just a head of IT 18 platoon in 1815 is
kind of pinned down and remember this
character from earlier Dennis Clark
Dennis Clark was the was the guy that
pulled him aside and said hey you need
to take command in this company well
like I said Dennis Clark or I thought
I'd remembered I was right Dennis Clark
was a was an artillery guy that called
an artillery so here we go back the book
I was saved by Captain Dennis Clark and
see our tame gunner Dennis had a
virtuoso touch where 25 pounders were
concerned sniping with one gun that
should get the buffers out he said with
total confidence moving his 19 set into
monitor radio moving his 19 set into my
platoon position no easy task in
daylight he gave us a display of the
most brilliant professionalism
we had come to expect from the 94th
field regiment by firing with only one
gun and making his mean point of impact
beyond the Dyke containing the Germans
he slowly decreased the range yard by
yard until one shell exploded in the
dike out came five very wet and shaken
Panzer grenadiers 's during this episode
all the platoon had to remain in the
bottom of their slit trenches because
Dennis's shells came over our positions
with minimum clearance I doubt if any
experienced infantry officer would deny
that the Royal Artillery during the
Second World War were the most
professionally competent people in the
British Army so again an interesting
dichotomy because in the beginning he
talks about how the artillery can trap
them because it's being used in this
broad plan that's locking in where
there's no deviation but here he's
talking about how brilliant it is
because he's directly coordinating with
it he's explaining to the artillery
officer where to put those rounds what
the problem is and then letting the
artillery officers solve it so there's a
dichotomy there just like there's a
dichotomy with the snipers back to the
book after a few more days in the
orchard we were becoming increasingly
exhausted and our fighting efficiency
deteriorated this condition existed not
only in my company but throughout the
battalion consequently the news of a
move back to rest came as a colossal
colossal relief to us all but we did not
know who is going to take over our
positions the takeover was to be at
night and was to be carried out as
quickly as possible if the enemy
discovered it a determined attack could
cause endless confusion and slaughter
during the late afternoon of one
particularly unpleasant day
Douglas appeared at the company
commander appeared with an American
captain and two lieutenants from a
parachute battalion of the 101st
Airborne Division they patted around the
company area in their rubber-soled boots
with the eyes of the whole company
following them so 101st is coming in to
relieve them
having wreckin ordered our area the
Americans returned to the company HQ to
discuss administrative points for the
takeover the plan was for the American
company commander to bring his company
down the main road in single file along
the edge of the ditch when the head of
the column reached our company HQ they
would be met by guides from each of our
platoons to lead the American platoons
to their positions as soon as they were
on the ground our platoons will withdraw
and assemble on the road
this may sound simple in practice at but
at night in close contact with the enemy
it certainly was not this type of
operation leaves two companies
particularly vulnerable during the
handover a determined enemy could attack
and turn the operation into a massacre
this is one of and I've said this before
on the podcast one of the hardest things
to do is link up with friendly forces on
the battlefield and if you're under fire
it's it's even harder so this one
they're trying to do it not under fire
trying to sneak and make it happen
back to the book the rest of the day was
spent packing making sure the enemy
noticed nothing of this nted activity we
put our spare ammunition onto the
carriers with great coats and blankets
the whole afternoon was strangely quiet
there was no activity from the enemy and
we in turn kept quiet the Sun went down
amid a fiery sky looking east the sky
was threatening li gray I went around I
went round my positions with sergeant
Kingston before the Americans arrived
all my men looked tired and could hardly
muster a smile as I went from slit to
slit many had contained two men and now
contained only one together with some
momento of his former made a mess tin or
a blood-stained jacket even a packet of
cigarettes wet and limp with Dew I
wondered how many more mementos would be
there when the Americans were relieved
about an hour later the Americans
arrived they loomed up in the darkness
by the roadside padding along in the
rubber-soled boots without a whisper I
fought at the time what
blended troops they were and how
excellent their equipment I wasn't
particularly impressed by the silent and
quick way they were led by their squad
commanders to our section positions so
there come the Americans to relieve them
one hundred and first Airborne Division
who's just outstanding soldiers they're
just awesome and we worked with them I
mean one of my platoons in Ramadi or
could live with them the first of 506
the band of brothers and you can tell
their reputation that the guys in Ramadi
upheld that standard in every possible
way but it's rooted all the way back to
these soldiers right here sounds like
this is what struck me when I read that
I was like oh this this that that
tradition of excellence in that unit has
gone from world war ii from these guys
right here and it's that same attitude
that I saw with guys in Ramadi the same
attitude all right now he makes a
statement here about this whole big
operation which was called Market Garden
which was this giant operation to try
and cut off the Germans seize multiple
bridges and there was three bridges they
were trying to seize and it it didn't
reach its full effect it wasn't like a
complete mission success they didn't
achieve every objective that they wanted
to so here we go back to the book Market
Garden was a sad operation complete
success coming so close and a stroke the
war in Europe could have been finished
in 1944 undoubtedly mistakes were made
both by the first Airborne Division
particularly their planners and also by
30 Corps and there was no shortage of
bad luck however in my experiences in my
experience most battles are riddled with
misfortunes and mistakes and the suit of
the sort found in this operation it was
not a failure because the ground was
taken and a prerequisite to both
operation veritable and the Rhine
crossings
wasn't like a total failure back to the
book I'm convinced that had the supreme
commander General Eisenhower given
Market Garden the unqualified support
that it justified it would have totally
succeeded despite its crop of pack Co
errors and planning and execution
I suppose it was just one more casualty
of the American mania for dispersal of
effort however it was without a doubt
the most exciting and imaginative leap
land battle in which eighteen platoon
ever fought and I'm proud to have taken
part so he's talking about folks of
effort he's talking about you if you
spread yourself out too thin you're not
going to you're not going to make it
happen we call that prioritizing execute
what's the biggest priority let's put
our resources there we didn't do that
and therefore didn't get a full mission
success now of course what resources
were there what was available there's no
one has unlimited resources no one if
you have that you have no issues right
and just crush problems with manpower
all right so now they're moving beyond
Market Garden and planning actually
planning he's planning a patrol through
a village back to the battle school
teaching at the time prescribed a
strength of twelve to twenty four a
fighting patrol here again my instincts
and experience did not conform to their
teaching he's a rebel
how can you command and control that
number of men in the dark particularly
in a skirmish Douglass the completely
under tolerant of the absent abstinence
II of my opinions on these matters left
the planning to me so cool Douglass's
little decentralized command you figure
out your plan then I like this the
composition of the patrol I based on
personalities and not all to battle
school a toward a numbers so imagine
that your your planning based on the
personalities of the individuals you
have the countryside being comparatively
open I decided to take a brand gun being
steady Williams and filmer would fill
the bill admirably if we ran into
trouble they could provide
ring fire for any assault we might make
or if things went badly they could cover
our withdrawal cover move obviously the
assault party required strengthening so
I decided to take a total patrol
strength of six men one Bren with seven
magazines and three armed with stands
with five magazines and 436 grenades
each plus a pair of wire cutters I
carried my Colt for grenades and an
umbrella
my umbrella had been a source of
amusement to the platoon since I had
found on the roadside in mook apart from
keeping me dry in or out of a slit
trench it was useful when prodding for
mines and brought some fun and color to
our lives
Jim Kingston and Doug Proctor fought
otherwise maintaining a disapproving
silence which I failed to notice so now
they're out on patrol moving down the
bank the right we crawled forward in the
mud and wet grass until we're almost
past the orchard from which came the
sound of digging and voices suddenly a
challenge came from our front followed
by a shower of stick grenades thrown
from a trench just inside the orchard on
our left one of the grenades landed
between my legs which were stretched out
and spread apart as I lay flat on the
riverbank there was no flash its
explosion seemed muffled and more
importantly owing to the soft mud I
received not a scratch the game was up
now the concentrated fire of the three
stands poured into the German into the
surprised Germans putting away my pistol
I threw three 36 grenades in quick
succession into the orchard hurriedly
reaching for my umbrella which eluded me
and then ignominy bignum aeneas lee we
beat her retreat so he gets a gray throw
on him and actually had this happening
to you Boozer some guys were out on a
patrol they were in an open field
they had cover from one side because
they had pre-planned how they were in
across this field and while they were
out there they got hit with machine-gun
fire and then mortars and they got
mortars dating like on them and luckily
because it was they were in like
muddy field like almost rice paddy
scenario the mortars when they hit they
went into the mud and so they exploded
but there was no all the district law
was all absorbed by the mud that's a
lucky day for to you bruiser right there
was we've also fired up with a cane
mashing up now they get back into a
defensive perimeter
I remember nights and defensive
positions like grosbeak stretched out in
a slit trench trying to get an hour
sleep before going around the platoon
positions to check that everything and
everyone was alright one felt and was
dirty and in the small hours of the
morning with bootlaces cutting into
swollen feet a foul-tasting mouth and an
aching stomach life had little to
commend it the dirt and discomfort
worried me more than the danger danger
for some reason that I've never
understood exhilarates but despite every
effort to keep clean it did not always
prove possible and that was unbearable
never once since I never once since have
I not been grateful to sink into a hot
bath or slide into a bed with clean
sheets we went to extraordinary lengths
to keep the dirt at bay once in Normandy
I washed and shaved in the rain water in
the deep ruts made by carts afterwards I
discovered that 400 yards away the
opposition had been overlooking my
ablutions a decent lawd who obviously
approved of my personal hygiene
so estate agent Caleb hey this guy's
just trying to be clean let's let him
continue back to the book during the
campaign a teen platoon carried out
three types of patrols reconnaissance
standing and fighting the first two
invariably useful because they provided
information if only negative fighting
patrols of which I led many were a
different and contentious proposition
unlike the German and American armies we
had a vigorous policy regarding fighting
patrols particularly at night and when
things were static on both sides on the
hence the thinking behind this policy
seemed to me at times to be superficial
and probably leftover from the Great War
World War one if when detailed for a
fighting patrol young officers queried
the wisdom of its given object there was
always the standard reply I quite agree
with you but it all helps to dominate
no-man's land there is undoubtedly a
certain validity of this argument but
was it worth the consequent loss of good
young officers and NCOs I doubt it
shortly after the war I was able to
briefly voice my reservations to my
illustrious Army Group commander that's
Montgomery by the way after giving me my
MC that's a Military Cross ribbon he
stepped back and said crisply patrolling
his bloody isn't it when I stammered
that it seemed a bit hard that it was
always the same people chosen for
patrols he replied with a twinkle in his
eye
one day you'll command a battalion and
you'll understand the problem for
20-year old sub alternative exchange
like this where the Field Marshal was
heady stuff but Monty's mischievous
humor and utter lack of philosophy
coupled with his single-minded
professionalism professionalism extended
his personal influence to the most
junior soldier in 21st Army Group we
felt we knew him and that he knew us
often he did so that's a great little
interaction you know he says patrolling
his bloody work isn't it and and Sidney
Gerry says yeah and the thing is it
seems like it's always the same platoon
that get made to do the patrolling and
he says one day when you're in charge of
battalion you'll understand why that is
and the reason why that is because
you've got the good guy and that's the
guy you're going to send out you're
going to rely on the people that get it
done
[Music]
this is an interesting they've got
another patrol that they're getting
ready to have to go out on and the
patrol was to probe between the roads
and advance if possible as far as the
forest beyond this its purpose was
indeed vague Douglas called me and
another platoon commander to company HQ
and explained it to us he then suggested
we should toss a coin for an
embarrassing situation arose I fought
that the winner would lead the Patrol
the other officer dissipated that the
loser would I lost the toss and got the
job so so imagine that you and me are
saying alright there's a dangerous
Patrol we're gonna have to do let's flip
for it
I'm thinking heads if I win I get to do
the Patrol you're thinking of you win
you don't have to do the Patrol not
everyone was quite as fired up I guess a
Sidney Gerry was and they wrap up a
relatively kind of uneventful patrol
relatively uneventful patrol and he
returns and they're having a cup of tea
and some biscuits sir in true British
form back to the book it was said that I
suddenly realized that I had been
commanding 18 platoon for three months
to be precise three months in two days
before I joined the battalion in
mid-july I had been warned warned that
my life expectancy would be about three
weeks it seems strange to me now but at
no time did I anticipate being either
wounded or killed I was just too busy
for thoughts like these and I become
totally absorbed in my grim
responsibilities in July I had been
ridden by doubt about my ability in my
innocence I'd expected success in battle
to be the prerogative of a victor the
durum which is like the champion
I now had no such doubts or illusions
furthermore I discovered just how much
soldiers resent and fear a young officer
who sees battle as a means to win his
Spurs
possibly at the cost of their lives so
when you grow Lynn and your mr. beating
your chests anywhere here you're going
to prove yourself to the world yeah
don't be that guy because you're going
to write checks with my life and we
don't like that my duty had become clear
to me it was to command 18 platoon with
quiet confidence providing I made them
only once my mistakes would be forgiven
if my soldiers were to go we're going to
place their very lives in my hands they
in return or acquired of me a serious
attitude to my profession if I could
achieve this with a light touch so much
the better that's an interesting comment
so you know he's saying look what they
require is that going to be serious
I'm going to be as serious as possible
and the it's like you ever heard the
term minimum force required yes yeah you
believe you probably said as a bouncer
right hey you got to use the minimum
force required so what are you saying is
that as a leader
the lighter touch the better the
lightest touch you can use to lead it is
better that's pretty cool statement
that's a good thing to think about thing
how can you lead with minimum force
every time you go and use more than you
then you need your your overexerting
right and who knows what kind of you
know you're taking away initiative you
might be stamping out morale so lead
with that minimum touch I like that
so at this point they're in a they're in
a position and there's three of these
mark 3 75 millimeter self-propelled
assault gun so they kind of look like
tanks they got big tracks they're
Germans they're German and they're and
they're sitting out in front of them
they're in a they're in a static
position the company's in a static
position and there's these the tanks
sitting there three of them and Douglas
looks at them thinking himself hey I
don't know what those they look like
they're functioning they don't look
damaged and so Douglas is saying okay
well we need to find out what's going on
even if there's no one even if there's
no one in them right now it could be a
place where they use snipers later so
someone's got to go check them out so
hit me Jerry the guy goes out alone kind
of sneaks out there he just stuff alone
a little bit more often this actually
does stuff alone there's another story I
didn't mention but at one point there he
hears noise look one of the guys reports
this nighttime may he hear noise in this
field they think there's an ax me out
there and he's like well there's one way
to find out so he I think he does grab
another guy in this occasion but it goes
out and he's going through this field
and it's like a cornfield or something
and he can't see and he's horrified and
he's trying to think of a reason to quit
he's like I just want to go back this
isn't smart and as he as this is taking
place and his fears climaxing all of a
sudden he hears a bunch of cows in the
field interrupt
so you're doing another solo operation
here trying to find out what these tank
like us all guns are doing out there
back to the book climbing up above the
tracks I put my head into the cupola
which was open a familiar and terrible
stench hit me inside was a charnel-house
six inches away a set of bared teeth set
in unrecognizable black and incinerated
lump
and in me beside it a charred and bony
arm reached up in agony spread on the
floor like a pool of tar lay the melted
remains of the driver I had entered
Dante's Inferno my head reeled and with
my mouth nose and lungs filled with the
stench of death I fell back to the
ground
although unmarked by fire on all on our
side all three assault guns had brewed
up and were blackened on their sides
which faced the enemy with no stomach to
look further I ran back to the company
forgetting to look for American Minds
never again did I look into a knocked
out tank or self-propelled gun I
reported to Douglas that nobody in the
right mind would use them for an
observation post or for any other
purpose later that day he asked that's
Douglas Dulles asked the commander of a
Sherman tank to fire some armor-piercing
shells into each of them positioning his
tank hold down beside 16 platoons
positions which were to our left the
tank commanders the tank commander first
selected the assault gun I had visited
his first shell hit slightly above the
tracks like the hammer of Vulcan a red
glow blossomed on the armor plate around
the point of entry and slowly faded it
was followed by a second and third shell
until a mirage of heat appeared above it
and for a second time the funeral pyre
blazed with an incandescent ferocity the
Sherman gunner then turned his attention
to the next assault on which despite
being penetrated by about six
armor-piercing rounds failed to brew up
his first shot at the third caused a
massive internal detonation no doubt due
to hammy nation stacked within a volcano
erupted from its cupola sending a dense
cloud of black smoke smoke and red
sparks into the air a truly magneri in'
for the warriors entombed within but it
revolted me for the rest of the day I
bleeded this communicated itself to my
NCOs and soldiers who stole mystified
glances at my grief for an unknown enemy
during the afternoon I wandered across
the road to a lone house where Dennis
Clarke had his observation post I was
looking for solace from a wise and good
friend the post was filled with gunner
officers there must have been a dozen of
them setting up their equipment in
preparation for an attack by to14
brigade this activity precluded any
solace for me immature and undisciplined
my imagination ran riot what were they
like these men whose already incinerated
remains had been blasted into oblivion
by the 75 millimeter shells of our
friend in the Sherman my attitude to war
was ambivalent undoubtedly I was parked
pacifist but despite an abysmal record
in mathematics and particularly in
geometry I was moderately logical for my
age this clearly ruled out total
dedication to pacifism I had previously
discussed the concept of conscientious
objection
with clergy of all denominations but
none of them could give me constructive
answers to my questions the privations
and suffering of 18 platoon hurt me an
infantry subaltern is faced with a
conflict which cannot be resolved one
gets emotionally involved with those
under one's command without this bond
few men will respond and consequently
little can be achieved however to win
battles decisions have to be taken and
orders given which at times may seem to
be a betrayal of this trust
before battle the commander must exude
confidence and enthusiasm whatever fears
his private thoughts may hold just how
thin a line divides this from deliberate
deception I call it the commander's
dilemma a pretentious phrase but there
is nothing to be done about it in
Nicholas Montserrat's book the cruel sea
poor commander Eriksson makes the point
with poignancy it's the war the whole
bloody war we've just got to do these
things and say our prayers at the end
there was another side possibly caused
by adrenaline danger attracted and
excited me I felt elated and until the
battle was over I was impervious to
exhaustion commanding a platoon in
battle demands not only a clear mind but
also considerable emotional force I
suspected is the same transmitted force
that exists between a conductor and
orchestra forty years later the dilemma
of my ambivalence is still unresolved
I find the suffering inflicted by war
unacceptable particularly amongst women
children and animals thank God I was
spared the horrific sights at fillets on
some days I am a pacifist and yet I'm
still attracted by the sounds of guns
and but for an extraordinarily happy
marriage would have found it difficult
to resist the lure of soldiering
[Music]
so what he calls the commander's dilemma
there's what I call the dichotomy in
leadership and that one is the premiere
of them all and that is as a leader as a
combat leader you are going to love your
men and care about them more than
anything else in the world and with that
you are going to make decisions and make
plans where you are sending those men
into a situation where they can be
wounded or killed and that's it
and that is the ultimate dichotomy of
leadership that is the hardest one to
balance
[Music]
back to the book a new officer arrived
named Humphries he used to play cricket
for worchestershire he came on the same
day that sergeant oxalá received a
well-earned commission in the field
Douglas told them about Sargent oxen and
with great consideration
he went to 17 platoons position to offer
his congratulations while they talked
just one salvo of 105 straddled them on
shell fell into second lieutenant
Auckland's slit trench and both were
killed instantly like me Ken auxin has
survived five months Humphreys survives
not a full day is there a mathematical
formula by which survival can be
calculated who are the survivors and can
they be recognized over the past 40
years I've often pondered this but still
offer no real answer I suspect however
that is something to do with attitude
attitude seems to me to be a parameter
which restricts not only our
relationships but also our creative
effort further common is unwise
Humphries one could argue had little
time to develop an attitude to our kind
of existence undoubtedly a
self-fulfilling circle develops
newcomers inexperienced in the perils of
the battlefield suffered the highest
casualties knowledge of what can and
what cannot be risked postpones the
fatal reckoning for the soldier for the
commander however Junior battlefield
experience will not only protect himself
but also all those under his command
[Music]
and that's the that's why training is so
important so important that's why when I
got done with you know deployment romani
that's why I went to training because I
knew that right there and I was thinking
you know I didn't know how long the war
was glassed and when we left for Mahdi
Ramadi was still horrible and when the
task unit came in relieved us man they
were getting after it and I didn't know
how long that was gonna last I mean it
ended up not lasting that much longer
that kind of intense fighting but it was
impossible to tell at that time we were
just barely seeing stuff start to get it
start to get better at the end of our
deployment just barely starting to see
the first indications of that back to
the book v Duke of Cornwall's light
infantry had attempted to attack joven
village through these ghastly woods and
had taken heavy casualties there
rain-soaked bodies littered the paths
and clearings while carrying out a
reconnaissance I came across one of
their sections lying across lying along
a small path facing the enemy at first I
fought them alive until I saw that the
studs on their boots were rusty and
their webbing equipment was bleached
with rain their battle dress was
starched with mud and their hands and
faces were Green German booby traps were
on or near many of the tracks and I was
told by the company commander of the 4th
Wilshire's from whom we took over the
position that some of the bodies were
also booby-trapped
don't try to bury them he said I was
temporarily commanding the company
because Douglass had been given a
well-deserved leave in Brussels
although militarily comparatively
uneventful Hoeven has a special place in
my memories it was rounded out my most
the most grisly and horrifying position
that we have her hold held but more
importantly it was the place of private
Charl
Ravens triumph Raven had fought in all
our battles until 1:12 which to him was
a yardstick of horror all subsequent
experience was compared with that his
first battle he was no soldier I doubt
if he influenced greatly any discourages
encounters or battles in which he took
part sometimes he was frightened and he
was so out of place on the battlefield
that I often wondered how he became an
infantry soldier before the war he had
been a clerk in North London I'm sure he
was a conscientious and loyal employee
and considerate and loving husband for
unlike most of us he was married
Raven had hidden depths and could be
inspired once in Normandy during a nasty
little Platoon attack up a sunken Lane
18 platoon was held up by the inevitable
unlocated Spann dose straining my eyes
to binoculars I was trying vainly to
locate these guns when I was handed a
steaming mug of tea he should have been
observing to his front but judging the
moment right he had brewed a Meston of
tea on a solid fuel stove by any
standards this was an inspired act he
was considerate with our reinforcements
pale unsure men some of whom until
recently had served in the Royal
Artillery and had been transferred to
infantry regiments to replace the
appalling losses incurred in the
Normandy bocaj beside them Raven looked
bronzed and weather-beaten
a hardened campaigner complete with a
German Luger pistol to prove it some of
the platoon regaled the reinforcements
with horrible tales from Normandy and
Elst as little more than a schoolboy I
found these stories amusing Raven did
not
fear for him was horribly real and never
to be joked about
he developed a paternal attitude toward
the newer and younger soldiers a
relationship devoid of patronage but
essentially one of kindly understanding
he spoke to me about it when he I
thanked him for his help I admit I'm
dead windy sir his extraordinary honesty
with himself on the rest of the tune
forbade him to attempt to hide the fact
Raven and over taxes nervous and
physical resources long before we
arrived in joven woods after two days in
the position he came to me late one
evening and asked my permission to
report sick the following morning I
suppose I should an thetic Lee had
refused but something made me hesitate
and avoid dealing directly with the
situation I said simply alright Raven
but do come see me before you leave he
didn't come the matter was never again
mentioned I can only surmise the
struggle which rage in his mind all that
night while he crouched in his water
long slit trench peering into the
sinister darkness of the wood I do know
however that in joven wood a
considerable moral triumph over stark
horror was achieved by a good man
unequipped for nature unequipped by
nature for war in my view the bravest of
the brave so that guy Raven had been
through all this stuff and just barely
held the line and finally he was going
to break climb he was going to break in
it and he comes to City Jerry and says
hey I'm gonna go sick tomorrow mm-hm
Timmy Jerry says ok come and see me
before you go it doesn't come back
doesn't come back to him doesn't go sick
back to the book infantry warfare is
wretched business it makes physical and
emotional demands on participants that
run contrary to all human instinct the
strong minority must quietly help the
weak majority to me that is the essence
of good teamwork and that jewel and the
crown of the British Army the regimental
system is the strong foundation upon
which we all knowingly or unknowingly
relied so there's going to be some
people that deal with it better than
others and you got to help here's a
situation
they set up early warning flares so
we'll trip wires in case due to to
notify them if the enemy is moving down
one of their flanks and here we go back
to the book after about 10 minutes it
passed we heard the popping of mortars
behind joven village and a concentration
of bombs fell in the fields where we had
laid the flares suddenly our left flank
was vividly illuminated as flare after
flare ignited knowing little about these
flares we had laid them with the trip
wires to talk had we allowed a degree of
slack the flares would not have ignited
my fault I should have known had to do a
little extreme ownership from Sidney
Gerry and therefore y'all sure now he's
talking about the attitudes of the
soldiers and how soldiers you know there
was a claim here at an article years
after the war that said that people Gil
people became brutal from the from the
war then here's what he says back to the
book does war brutalize one can only
speak from personal experience but I
think not certainly no soldier of mine
was made brutal rather the opposite war
developed an 18 platoon consideration
for comrades and humanity towards
civilians and prisoners of war I was
proud of my soldiers then and this
sentiment has increased with the passing
of years I would not suggest that the
naturally boodle might not find in war
an outlet for their brutality however
that war does not brutalize the type of
decent men the type of decent and fair
minded young English men whom I had the
very great honour to command
we were not an aggressive generation a
fact which may explain my failure to
understand some present-day attitudes in
the armed services particularly in the
Royal Marines and the parachute regiment
possibly a degree of personal aggression
is appropriate in troops are committed
to battle for comparatively short
periods like the Marines and the Paris
when the success of an operation depends
on ultra rapid action however in my
experience troops lose personal
aggression after about two months in
battle after three months they acquire a
mature compassion which in no way
detracts from their offensive capability
they simply know a lot more about war I
would suggest that personal aggression
should not be confused with offensive
spirit based on professional competence
and experience interesting cake that
aggression that you can maintain if you
it's not going to last forever and and
then you're gonna have to fall back on
duty and in that mature compassion which
isn't taken away from their offensive
capability interesting
back to the book on the 11th of January
we return to the south a fine yeah just
to go back to that one piece right there
dichotomy leadership there's a dichotomy
and everything and you know obviously
I'm a big proponent of being aggressive
and I also always talk about the fact
that there is such a thing as being too
aggressive you're running to your death
no not a good idea
not a good idea and there's probably a
good chance that when he talks about
people after two months of combat
everyone starts to develop a different
type of attitude also the people that
were ultra aggressive didn't make it
like the kid like the leader that he
talked about that was strutting around
the guy was ultra aggressive didn't care
about anything and he's dead yeah so
there's a balance you got to have that's
the dichotomy of leadership that's why
the economy of leadership is so
important and so hard to understand
back to the book on the day after the
battalion was relieved in joven woods
someone I expect I suspect it was the
adjutant Tim Watson decided that I
should enjoy 48 hours on leave in
Antwerp I was overjoyed the large hotel
although faded was still plush and
filled with officers including women 80s
officers from the various base units
stationed in the city just as I had left
the battlefield I was both disheveled
and soiled surrounded by the residents
many of whom were in service dress I
could not have felt more isolated and
lonely so he's getting some leave time
but he's showing up off the battlefield
grimy my first MIT visit was to a
magnificent white marble gentleman's
hairdressing salon in the basement of a
hotel without a word
the barber washed and rinsed my hair
twice before touching it with his
precious scissors and clippers I
remember the feeling of well-being as
climbing the stairs I returned to my
room next I took three very hot baths
one after the other to rid myself of
I'm both physical and emotional I think
I must have slept for 14 hours before I
rose shaved took another bath and
decided to explore the city a rather
creased battle dress was my best suit
and in this I descended the main
staircase into the lounge which was
filled with the resident officers all of
whom seemed to be annoyingly
self-assured I met a barrier I had
walked out of a world that I knew into
one where I was desperately unsure of
myself away from the battlefield this
world had no place for me I did not go
out to lunch go to night clubs or meet
the girls who were everywhere seemed to
be canvassing for these establishments I
had wandered too far into dark and smoky
battlefields across the sticks to find
solace or comfort in the bright lights
behind the blackout curtains of Antwerp
I longed to return to the battalion and
2-18 platoon which without my knowing it
had become my home with a light heart a
clean body flesh freshly laundered
clothes and refreshed by hours of
unbroken sleep I gladly climbed into the
3-ton truck that took me there years
later I found the same problem after I
left the army Antwerp had did a small
taste of the real world and as anyone
who has served with good soldiers on
grim battlefields will confirm
afterwards real life never seems real
again later
there was no 18 platoon to slink back to
and without a loving life it would have
proved intolerable
well that's the feeling that that we get
when you get done doing that job can
real life never seems real again in
comparison I know the vets that are
listening to understand that part back
to the book on 11 January we returned to
the South Holland's this time to gank
Anglet snow lay on deeply frozen ground
and life for the entry and life for the
infantry Manning their split trenches
became unbearable again the battalion
front was extensive D Company was in
reserve closed close to battalion
headquarters on the edge of town
fortunately gang L was on a reverse
slope which allowed us to move freely
during daylight hours the cold was
penetrating the oil in our automatic
weapons froze and until antifreeze
lubricants were issued our brands were
useless holding a wide front with large
gaps between our company positions
necessitated putting out many standing
patrols particularly at night the
privation suffered by these small
patrols usually a corporal and three or
four men or harder than the rest of us
some had hallucinations and if you were
exact evacuated suffering from exposure
keeping fit warm and clean became a
great effort conversation dried up the
platoon became quiet but never morose at
one stage I decided they needed cheering
up and I wandered around the section
post ready to chat with all of them it
was quite unnecessary I had wrongly
judged their mood they just wanted to be
left alone
now there's a begin by the book and read
the book there's a chaotic bottle battle
at a pace place called cleave and after
the Battle of cleave
he kind of debriefs here back to the
book what instructors at the school of
infantry would think about the fighting
cleave I shudder to think it resembled
no other battle in my experience I had
little control and it developed into a
section commanders battle looking back
over the years it seems military league
totally unprofessional a real Wild West
shoot-out tactically the Germans had
every advantage we were strung out in a
long column amid shattered buildings and
piles of rubbles with the groups of
parachute troops attacking from both
sides they could snipe at us and engage
with our with their span downs from
dozens of positions totally hidden by
piles of rubble they had the opportunity
to concentrate their counter-attacks on
the narrowest of fronts but failed to do
to do so so they failed to focus their
efforts I can only assume that we had
the psychological advantage the
circumstances being so chaotic and
disorganized perhaps being Germans they
could not overcome their instinct for
organization and tidiness in the end
they departed possibly and discussed
leaving us undisputed victors
on another attack
the Germans at this point are retreating
and they can see that they're retreating
fearing that the retreating parachute
troops would make a stand on the edge of
the wood I increased the rate of advance
joining lance-corporal Porteous in the
forward section running across the level
crossing I suddenly found myself face to
face with a German platoon complete with
the mg34
fortunately the gun was mounted on a
tripod which was unusual and could not
be traversed in our direction from a
drainage channel on the left of the road
a parachutist leaped up swathed and
camouflage veil pointing his Schmeisser
at me from about 10 yards range he fired
a whole magazine of about 30 rounds it
was like watching a slow running silent
movie I didn't hear the chatter of the
Schmeiser
but I do remember seeing the stream of
empty cartridges cartridge cases fly
from the German machine-gun miracles do
indeed happen one 9-millimeter bullet
went through my beret messing my head
literally by a hair's width
another went under the epaulette of my
jacket penetrating the webbing across
brace the webbing crossed brace of my
equipment and grazing my right shoulder
a third bullet ricocheted off the
surface of the road and disintegrated
the jacket finally lodging in the palm
of my right hand
then came the anticlimax the German
looked at me in amazement through his
Schmeiser and I with a shrug of the
shoulders he surrendered my natural
elation was short-lived behind me lay
Lance Corporal Porteous shot through the
heart some of the German platoon ran
away across the open fields to our left
and were cut down by rapid fire brand
gun by sergeant Kingston section which
now lined the railway track to the left
the road the remainder the enemy came
towards us over the level crossing with
their hands raised
we took fifty
prisoners now they're moving along and
they are clearing some cottages and they
get to this one cottage filled with
rough wooden bunks and it obviously
served as an air-raid shelter the house
having been found clear of enemy Jack
Lee was off his guard as he descended
the steps suddenly from under a pile of
blankets left the fanatical German
paratrooper the only fanatical German
paratrooper we encountered the entire
battle a large man he sees Jack around
the throat in an attempt to strangle him
private flute rose to the challenge in a
bound he was down the steps and with a
mighty lunge transfixed the German on
his bayonet a brave lad he undoubtedly
saved Lance Corporal Lee's Life just
eight days before losing his own the
German was indeed unlucky as it was the
only occasion throughout the campaign on
which 18 platoons bayonets were bloodied
we usually used them to open food cans
having checked the platoon positions and
arcs of fire for the Bryn's exhaustion
hit me I fell into a deep sleep during
the evening a senior officer I
understand it was either the brigade or
divisional commander came out to my
company position when he asked to speak
to me sergeant Kingston refused to have
me awakened I am sure that Jim was the
most diplomatic about it
but it says much for our visitors
humanity that he let it go by
another attack a and C companies were
unleashed and passing B company secured
their objectives against some opposition
there is now our turn D company advanced
across the flat open fields down the
left-hand side of the main road into
zanten the name of the city village
casualties from the preceding companies
and the opposition lay all around about
300 yards short of the town were
extremely accurately engaged by a
battery of 105's some of their shells
exploded on the hard surface the road
ear-splitting detonations and
frightening fragmentation pieces of
shell casing hummed and whined around us
one coiling piece embedded itself with a
thud into the chunk of a tree a few
inches from my right ear was the only
time in the whole campaign when I
regretted throwing away my steel helmet
I think it was the accuracy and the
intense noise of the shelling that
caused it one of 18 platoons lance
corporals a big man who had served
honorably since Market Garden went to
pieces there was a pathetic sight and to
everyone's credit he was quietly removed
from the battle he had passed his limit
and nothing more can be said
[Music]
so you don't know these guys are brave
at one moment and then a week a month
two months four months they can't do it
anymore they get across the Rhine now
they're fully in Germany there's a
little bit of a lull in the fighting
back to the book early one morning while
we were waiting for our supporting armor
to arrive our Padre John Williams drove
over asius after wandering around the
platoon for a chat he suggested he
suggested that we should go for a short
stroll I had now been commanding 18
platoon for over eight months and I
suspect that our adjutant Tim Watson a
kindly soul had asked him to find out
what shape I was in we had not gone far
into the next field when we came across
some grisly remnants one of our
artillery shells must have exploded
right at the feet of a German soldier
who had been digging a slit trench his
splintered and twisted Spade lay beside
laid by the side of that half dug trench
beside which was a smaller shell hole he
had been disintegrated into small pieces
of flesh and bone which lay scattered
all over the field had I been on my own
I would no doubt have shuddered and
quickly departed from this horror draped
over a wire fence nearby lay a parachute
which our extraordinarily brave Padres
spread out as a shroud on the cold and
damp grass then stooping he walked
around the field a lonely figure
reverently picking up every piece of
that poor soldier to my shame I stood
and watched him I lack the courage to
help
somewhere beneath those flat damp fields
just north of the Rhine that poetic
pathetic bundle must still lie
[Music]
now they're an attack again but it seems
like things are going their way and
we're going he's kind of giving a brief
to his to his runner when all of a
sudden he hears yelling back in the book
sir they're charging us sure enough from
about 150 yards ahead and well spread
out line of about 20 Germans were
putting in a bayonet charge brave lads
they didn't stand a chance
I gave no orders except ceasefire not
one got within 75 yards of us a few
minutes later a procession of Germans
with stretchers and a huge red flag
emerge from the village behind when they
were close to their casualties they
hesitated so I stood up and waved them
on all our unarmed stretcher bearers and
they moved across our front collecting
their dead and wounded when they had
finished their tasks of mercy one of
them I think he must have been a German
medical officer turned and saluted in
our direction I returned the salute and
with that gesture the tiny Battle of
cinder and ended in Bremen little over a
month later one of our stretcher bearers
Lance Corporal Jay Stevens was killed by
a German grenade as he went - 10 -
wounded German soldier 18 platoon
remembering syndrome were justifiably
outraged by such on soldierly behavior
[Music]
there is a mathematical formula
aggression increases the further one
goes behind the lines opposing infantry
with few exceptions like the SS are
joined by a natural bond of mutual
compassion which few but the aristocracy
of the battlefield can understand the
public influence no doubt by writers
with literal no experience of battle
have strange and sometimes silly ideas
about what makes a good soldier
ill-informed
television programs have added to this
misunderstanding few professions can be
have been so misleadingly caricatured I
had I been asked at the time before
August 1944 to list the personal
characteristics which go to make a good
infantry soldier my reply would indeed
have been why to the mark wide of the
mark
plank most I no doubt would have
suggested only masculine ones like
aggression physical stamina a hunting
insect instinct and competitive nature
how wrong I would have been I would now
suggest the following firstly sufferance
without which one could not survive so
he's listing what he thinks the most
important characteristics for for an
infantry soldier are the first one is
sufferance the ability to suffer
secondly a quiet mind which enables a
soldier to live in harmony with his
fellows through all sorts of
difficulties and sometimes under
dreadful conditions as in a closed
monastic existence there is simply no
room for the assertive or acrimonious
thirdly below no less important a sense
of the ridiculous which helps the
soldiers surmount the unacceptable add
to these a reasonable standard of
physical fitness and a dedicated
professional competence and you have a
soldier for all seasons none of the
soldiers or NCOs who made 18 platoon
what it was resembled the characters
portrayed
most books and films about war all quiet
sensible unassuming and some by any
standard for heroes if I now had to
select a team for a dangerous mission
and my choice was restricted to stars of
the sports field or poets I would
unhesitatingly recruit from the ladder
[Music]
very interesting and you know obviously
you have to put this in the context of
of his time but well there's no doubt
that I mean you get a sports star
especially these days those guys that
are getting paid 20 30 40 million
dollars a year to play a game that
they're probably not going to be the
best at suffering in a trench
interesting and I think the key point of
that is what he's going back to what he
talked about earlier someone that can
think someone that can think someone
that is not trapped in thinking the same
thoughts as everyone else which
certainly an artist or a poet has to be
outside the box of normal thought
otherwise they become they don't become
that right
in this situation his platoon is kinda
pinned down and there's an air-raid
shelter which has someone in it is
firing these things called a Panzerfaust
which is like a it's kind of like a
bazooka or like an RPG looking thing and
he sees where it's coming from
and he sees that it's this shelter but
he doesn't know who's in the shelter
here we go back to the Kulu who else was
in the shelter women and children
sheltering more enemy soldiers with more
Panzerfaust and Spanos we were in a
vulnerable situation it was no good
pushing forward and ignoring the Menace
lurking inside that shelter I could have
sent two or three men to clear it
however experience had taught me that
when clearing cellars that the first man
sent in is invariably killed instead
concentrated fire was poured into the
entrance including a Fiat bomb around us
the battle still raged and no
opportunity arose for medians for me to
inspect the consequences of an awful
decision nevertheless my duty was to win
battles and not to gamble with the lives
of my soldiers by fussing over too
sensitive a conscience so there you go
there's dichotomy for you at the one
hand he's looking at this shelter figure
there might be women and kids in there
but at this moment in time he doesn't
have time to find out and doesn't have
time to to take of the most cautious
route so they hammer it with machine-gun
fire and some some anti-tank rounds he
never even goes to look but he knows
that he can't hit his duty is to win
battles and he can't did he dally
because he has a sensitive conscious
doesn't work
back to the book Bremerhaven was our
final objective it was 5th May 1945 19
days before my 21st birthday think about
what you were doing you were told I am
that's like so interesting ready to
break out we were concentrated at whilst
at about 20 miles north of Bremen when
the end became and by the end I mean the
end of the war 129 brigades order was
stand down and spliced the Mainbrace
which is a military effective Navy term
splice the Mainbrace means like drinking
light is lit you can drink the war is
over I had just given orders for our
small partner brigades move forward
against 15 Panzer Division one of the
famous Africa Corps formations in 1983
Jim Kingston gave me his copy of those
orders which he had kept all those years
reaction to the end of the war like
aggression increased further behind the
lines one went the natural aristocracy
of the battlefield the infantry having
fired a photo joy of fairy lights curled
up and slept we had learned too much to
indulge in shallow demonstrations so
everyone's all fireworks and getting
crazy these guys are like cool I'm going
to sleep since July we had come a long
way from the Normandy beachhead the
battalion had lost 47 officers and 1266
NCOs and private soldiers killed or
wounded after July 31st 1944 no member
of 18 platoon was put on a charge no one
went absent or deserted of the original
36 NCOs and soldiers who had landed in
Normandy only corporal Cheeseman
remained
one man many came after them and lasted
a few days weeks or months few I was
able to thank adequately I doubt if any
of them realized how much I personally
owed a teen platoon when I joined them
on 31st to July I was naive and gouge
due to a narrow upbringing except for a
passionate love of music my intellect
and emotions were unstimulated my
achievement at school had been abysmal
my mind was undisciplined and confidence
in myself nil this was rapidly swept
away probably even three weeks certainly
before we crossed the sin on the 20th of
August discovering an ability to command
a group of men some frightened and
bewildered produced a newfound
confidence particularly since I seemed
to be able to achieve it quietly and
without acrimony or fuss having to
improvise tactics to overcome the
shortcomings of battle school training
also helped it proved to me that in some
circumstances older and more experienced
than I otherwise that I could be wrong I
suspect that as an only child I had been
brought up in too much of my elders a
new world had opened before me
forethought and planning were demanded
imagination and instinct too was that
apparently quiet Normandy Lane lethal
the intense spandau fire and more during
along a dike was it a prelude to an
enemy's withdrawal did the orchard in
front of the village hide 88 my judgment
in these things had proved equal to
better than most of than the most and it
was the making of me it also brought a
few problems I'm now only able to plan
and run things in my way as a result I'm
probably unemployable
however I would never wish to change
places with the shy hesitant boy whom
circumstances put in command of a teen
will tune age 20 I was far too young and
inexperienced to appreciate that an
infantry platoon was the finest command
in the army and that's the success or
failure of a battle so often lay solely
in the hands of a young officer after
careful reflection I doubt that at any
time since the war have I carried the
burden of responsibility that I bore as
a subaltern in battle when an Army Corps
division or brigade was committed to
battle it was the battalion company in
platoon commanders who took over the
mantle of responsibility from the
generals from the generals and
brigadiers in close country forests and
street fighting the platoon commander
became the linchpin only the company and
platoon commanders particularly the
latter were able to have close
relationship with their soldiers which
is a prerequisite for having
above-average success failure by one
infantry company could wreck a
divisional battle plan conversely
gallant success like B company at Zanten
underwrote the italians victory again i
would emphasize the analog with the bond
of professional respect between a great
conductor and the members of a symphony
orchestra without which a truly great
performance is not possible outstanding
performances cannot be arranged in the
concert promoters office they are
created by some magic by the conductor
and players in rehearsal and performance
similarily while senior commanders
appreciated the strengths and weaknesses
of their battalions and brigades they
cannot extract a great performance from
the rifleman upon whom victory depended
only the company of platoon commanders
supported by their NCOs could ensure
that 42 years on I get consider
satisfaction from 18 platoon successes
more so than I got at the time so those
are his thoughts and he's the wars now
over and a few days after the war ended
well go to the book after collar
inoculations we were conducted into the
world of Frankenstein nothing had
prepared us for what we now experienced
not hail 112 not Mountain shown else or
Hoeven could compete with this horror
before the incredulous eyes of a teen
platoon spread over acres of
delightfully wooded countryside was a
factory of death emaciated bodies
resembling wax effigies of an alien race
from a strange and distant planet filled
many pits the stench of death and the
sight of such highly industrialized
human degradation left my soldiers
speechless private Macy D company's deep
driver aptly summed it up there is now
no doubt that we have fought a just war
that's after they saw the concentration
camps obviously back to the book within
a month of the war ending 21st Army
Group was required to supply junior
officers for the 14th army in Burma
limpy the commanding officer decided
that I should be one of them
and by then being intent on a military
career I was not inclined to argue I
would gain useful experience of jungle
warfare of which I knew nothing about so
they're getting order still a war going
on in the Pacific
oh you wrapped up pushing from Normandy
through Germany through their surrender
yes well we need we need people to go to
fight in Asia we need people in Burma I
was totally unprepared for the platoons
for the emotions that were unleashed
immediately after I was deprived of 18
platoon as a jeep took me away from the
battalion a ghastly desolation engulfed
me I felt like a small boy on his way to
a grim and unknown boarding school the
pleasures of commanding 18 platoon in
peacetime were being denied me
[Music]
and it's interesting so he gets pulled
away from this platoon and any good
thing to talk about what happened to the
guys that survived they knew in half
I found this part to be fascinating in
the how these people went back to normal
life back to the book Jim Kingston was
demobilized in January 1946 and two
months later he returned to a civilian
post with the Bristol Corporation
electricity department retired in 1975
never married
Doug Procter returned home to his wife
and baby son and Nottingham in March of
1946 found the transition from Army to
civilian life painless returning to his
accounting post in the coal industry
owen Cheeseman during the first few days
of a demobilization his wife died
miserable and forlorn he returned to his
old job in Covent Garden and a few years
later he met and married Bella who in
his own words was a comfort and
inspiration to him Charles Raven joined
the London Transport as a bus conductor
later transferring to the clerical staff
and rose by hard work and study to be a
garage inspector Joe Thomas and George
Harris went into the building trade
industry and Bridgewater
[Music]
surprisingly just incredibly normal
paths after this incredibly not normal
life and and what happened to Sidney
Gerry so here's what happened to Sidney
Gerry back to the book arriving England
on 9th July 1945 I reported to the
holding battalion of the Hampshire
regiment at Westgate on sea and was
immediately sent on 28 days leave after
a night out in London with three friends
also Burma bombed I telephoned my
parents and found them away trapping
them to Bognor Regis I caught a train
from Waterloo and went to see them
staying at the same hotel as my parents
were flight lieutenant Jack Weatherly's
widow Peggy and their three-year-old
daughter and we're staying at the same
hotel as his parents at once a bond of
deep understanding and affection
developed between us in August an atom
bomb was dropped and so at a stroke my
visit to Burma was rendered pointless so
too in my heart was a military career I
soldiered on in Libya and Palestine with
the first Battalion of my own regiment
for two more interest in years and
finally was demobilized in May of 1947
more than a week of leaving the army I
attended a job interview the managing
director who saw me a pale and thin
lipped man was a business acquaintance
of a relative he eyed me coldly slowly
and precisely from his desk he lifted a
ruler which he lewdly pointed at my face
I understand that you made a slight name
for yourself from the war be that as it
may people like you Jerry should
remember that while you have been
gallivanting around the world most of my
staff had remained loyal to the cup
to the company if you can give me one
valid reason why I should even consider
you for any position I should be
interested to hear it I nearly hit him
now I wish that I had quickly grabbing
my hat and umbrella I rose and told him
that if he was the last man in the world
I would rather starve than work for him
with that I left my heart pounding and a
foul taste in my mouth
I walked aimlessly through miles of
streets wishing that I was back on some
battlefield with real men soldiers like
18 platoon Armistice Day brings its
problems peg and I would like to go to
church we used to go but found almost
without exception a lack of perception
and sensitivity amongst the clergy we
suffered one Armistice Day sir sermon
devoted to the curates theory that war
being a crime against humanity all
chivalry must therefore be hypocritical
I wondered whether the Germans
stretcher-bearers and their wounded at
synderen would have agreed I took
offense peg and I have a lot to mourn
she Jack Weatherly and I 18 platoons
dead perhaps it is expecting too much of
any one to understand intense grief
particularly that of a now ageing
platoon commander who had to lead some
of his men to their deaths
we now spend Armistice Day quietly at
home with our ghosts
memory is abound during the night I made
a habit of wandering around the platoon
position so that each of my soldiers
could talk to me I learned a lot they
talked about their families and their
future hopes I hardly had to contribute
to those whispered conversations that
some times took place in the dead of
night or in the cold gray light just
before dawn I think it may have helped
my soldiers to have a confidant
invaluable experience of human nature
I now treasure the memory weapons also
left memories the monotonous repetitive
bursts of the Bren the hysterical shriek
of the mg 42s for furious rate of fire
and the lethal chatter of the stands and
schmeiser's all contribute all
contributed to the cacophony of battle
tracer bullets seared themselves into
memory fired from a distance that / out
their parabola approached almost lazily
until suddenly like a swarm of fiery
demons they accelerated directly past
one's head with ear-splitting cracks I
shall never forget the brain splitting
shock wave as mortar bombs detonated nor
the rending of the atmosphere when a
stick of never wore fur bombs straddled
one slit trench my memory is stocked
with smells the metallic stench of dead
cattle in Normandy the pungent odor of
German prisoners and the vile
penetrating chemical smell from a newly
plowed shell crater strange fleeting
memories to why in circumstance of great
danger did the palms of my hands moisten
making it difficult to grip the butt of
my pistol
why on pitch-black
sites full of menace was it possible to
discern enemy movement by fixing my
straining eyes slightly to excite it
sounds foolish but I swear that it works
after 40 years I am sure I could still
prime a 36 grenade in total darkness or
load the magazines of a Colt automatic
pistol I remember are dead their souls
departing they lay awkwardly like
bundles of discarded clothing at bed
burg lance-corporal Porteous lay by
their railway crossing in an instant he
had gone leaving his body clothing and
equipment empty at health and boom
private Jones died with a tiny cry lost
in the chill winter air as the bullet
took him from us memories are not all
sad rarely since as my adrenaline flowed
as an advance to combat with all the
senses alert one lived for a few hours
sometimes for day at a concert pitch
like a drug it captivated me I wanted
more totally absorbed one pressed on
until objectives had been seized and I
flopped as I had never done since I
remember the mood of pulsating
expectancy during the last few hours
before battle old trusted friends like
Dennis Clark and Bramley Hancock would
arrive to tie up their artillery support
others troop commanders from the
Sherwood Rangers would appear almost in
party mood to marry up with us the very
air was vibrant with excitement and good
fellowship
no acrimony simply an exercise and
willing cooperation to help us the
infantry overcome the day's grim task
but my most treasured memory is the
simple and sincere affection which
existed between us all based on mutual
trust
it was the cornerstone of the platoons
success and it survives unchanged to
this day this is tinged with regret
regret because Jim Kingston Owen
Cheeseman and particularly Doug Proctor
did not receive any recognition they so
richly deserved Jim and Owen were
mentioned dispatches but Doug was left
unrewarded over the years this omission
has troubled me particularly because I
had not been so had I not been so young
and inexperienced more notice might have
been taken of my representations I have
no doubt that they all learned a
military medal on more than one occasion
and I their platoon commander failed
them in this respect I miss my soldiers
the warmth of their presence comforted
me and their humor restored my spirits
in the brutal world of infantry warfare
although few of them realized it and
certainly none would admit it their
behavior was noble their absence left a
void which but for an exceptionally
happy marriage would have certainly
drawn me back into the Army for the
comfort that only a soldier can
understand strangely I have never since
considered myself anything but a soldier
and that wraps up that book and I'm not
sure if I have much to add because
[Music]
because Sydney Jerry seems to capture it
and so much of what he talks about
explains so much not only about about
being a soldier but also about what it's
like when a soldier is no longer a
soldier to to miss the adrenaline to
miss that singular focus to miss seeing
men at their best at their noblest
to miss the men themselves your comrades
your friends your brothers to miss what
he calls so perfectly
that simple and sincere affection that
exists in a platoon in affection that
I'm not sure exists anywhere else then
you can we talk about when I start
talking about a seal platoon about how
that's the best thing in the world and
Sidney Gerry captures it better than me
you miss the mission then you miss the
men and of course you miss the fallen
as the British call them the glorious
dead and you wonder what would have
become of them where would they be now
and you you wonder why why then
why was it down
[Music]
and you know I talk about the gift right
the gift that they gave us that the
Fallen have given us this gift of
freedom and this gift of life but
there's there's more there's more
because you see the rest of us we grow
old some time passes us by and that's
that simple and sincere affection that
Sydney Geri describes it changes as we
change it ages
as we age but the fallen do not change
but fallen do not age time has no effect
on them they remain they remain young
and bold and brave and unconquered
and so we remember them that way as they
were and as they will always be
our heroes héroes a walk no more and yet
walk everywhere with us who smile no
more and yet they never stop smiling
heroes who live no more
yet never stop living
our friends who shine no more and yet
never stop shining
then that is the other gift that they
give us
the fortune
to bask in their light and to remember
[Music]
they make it that's all I've got for
tonight
[Music]
so echo maybe if you could talk about
something else for a little while yeah I
would appreciate it sure you know a part
that kind of stood out and we talked
about this before where there is that
part where you know the Germans the
bayonets they're attacking 150 yards
wings and they just get mowed down they
just get killed and then the red flag
comes up stretchers come out and one
sees fire it's kind of like you know
they're following these specific rules
and then so they collect the bodies and
they salute kind of like okay we're good
and then he salutes back okay solid no
game on essentially game on now but this
is like a war though you know it's
different I mean you kind of get that
same feeling way on a lower level
obviously but like your watch like a UFC
fight and then the round ends there and
then the guys kind of like bunk up for
good round you know for sure but two
seconds ago you guys were trying to
knock the guy out you know just like in
this situation two seconds ago these
guys were coming to kill you and you
killed them killed them
yeah boom it happened round over
you know let's essentially continue
following the rules and it it's weird
because it's less about the rules and
more about like their respect
you know it is and on top of that you
can pile on the fact that when they were
in joven woods
the Germans had booby-trapped the
British body so they were just laying
there they didn't they didn't get this
they didn't get the same respect back
yeah but I think that's one thing that
that Sydney Gerry is very intent on
throughout the book is that regardless
of how depraved the enemy acts they are
going to take the high road yeah and you
know I think that's why this book is
this book they give this book everyone
at UH at Sandhurst which is the the
military academy he gives everyone
that's a great reason why because he
sets a standard with his troops and they
hold that standard through regardless of
the way the enemy because they don't
lower themselves to that behavior you
know the worst atrocity that gets
committed by his soldiers is when they
spank a waffen-ss guy on the ass yeah
you know that's that's why this book is
so powerful and and you know there's a
lot of the book is very it's very you
notice there's stuff in there that you
you just aren't ready for right even
when he was talking about the the traits
that someone should have and you know
when you start thinking about it right
you know he's right and if you had the
choice between getting some meathead
that was going to go do your bidding
even though he might look like a big
beast and he's gonna but then if you
think about how that guy can act when
things get tough or when things become
ethically challenging yeah how's that
person gonna act so these are it's and I
love the fact also that then he's
killing people she's you know it's easy
to get caught up in the fact that he's
wearing corduroy pants and he's got this
there's a part of another part I didn't
didn't go over the podcast but there's
there's a group of German there's a
German some kind of artillery piece and
an artillery team and they're getting
the the Brits are getting their guns
dialed in to the team and they're going
to start killing them and they make a
run for it and they have horses and
there's like six guys and some horses
towing this this artillery piece away
and Sidney Gerry feels happy he's happy
that the especially happy the horses
like he doesn't like seeing the the
animals get killed and so he's actually
happy that these guys escape and then he
just says you know well that's wrong
because these guys didn't come back and
kill my soldiers so he does a he you can
see how hard it is
for someone to be in these situations
where you have the good conscience which
wants to do the right thing and at the
same time you got to kill people yeah
and that's a that's what makes combat so
hard yeah and you can can you get to
thinking back remember the Christmas
yeah the Christmas trees yeah where the
Germans the Germans kind of in that
situation they initiated that right
there they're like sounds like a mutual
initiation but yeah yeah if you remember
that particular story but I think
overall it was almost like a mutual
initiation but yes and that particular
story there was sort of a voice that
says hey yeah okay I don't cheat you
whatever and yeah man it's just crazy
how that can tenant emerge from these
situations where guys are just straight
up gang blown to pieces on purpose by
the way not you know not like some
tragic accident like this that's the
intent that's the intention then they
want to just stop and sing together
please soccer and then the next day by
the way they're going back to killing
each other on mass yeah dang yeah that's
that's the thing about you know that
again you know this a book like this is
so revealing of human nature because
business people have to do the same
thing yeah you know if you're a business
person and your business is losing money
well guess what you might have to do cut
staff you know if you got it and you you
don't want let's say we're working with
a small business or you go you've got a
small business you've got 20 people you
know all those 20 people yeah it's not
like a nameless person that you're
firing right when you let go four or
five people because you need to save
money next quarter or you're gonna lose
your building yeah guess what you're
going to know those people yeah and so
it's the same dichotomy where this boss
who wants to take care of his people
just like Sidney Jerry wants to take
care of his men and all of a sudden the
only way to do your mission is you got
to kill it you got are going to get some
of these people killed you're going to
fire some of these people otherwise our
plant shuts down otherwise we can't go
forward yeah and everyone dies no one
has a job now so the similarities again
that's why it's the
why these things about war reveal so
much about human nature which is really
what this podcast is about it's about
human nature and the better you
understand human nature there's two
things that can happen
number one the better you can lead other
people but equally as important if not
more important is if you understand
human nature you can understand yourself
ya can understand the decisions that
you're making you can understand why
something's bothering you you can
understand what you need to conclude so
that you can move forward in the best
possible way and if you don't understand
human nature you're you're in that so
understanding yourself yeah and these
books allow you to gather it and garner
so much of that yeah
see all the similarities so many all the
time
I remember in it's not junior high yeah
hi um maybe really high school so when I
used to play Pop Warner football where
my best friend played for a different
team but we're all you know it's in Pop
Warner it's different it's not by school
it's by like region you know like in
that region I guess town mmm the pump
boy in the region so I don't think
anyway so the you know my best friend at
the time she was Byron he who became a
pilot by the way I think it involves her
yeah army or Marines I forget anyway
um he played for a different team but we
were best friend so it was kind of that
thing you know where you're friends with
the guys but then you know you go on the
battlefield and you guys are battling
your back to friends just weird yeah
you're not killing him though no way
different yeah Anderson did you ever see
that in our Iraq like any of that like I
don't know compassion you know yeah yeah
for sure even with the enemy time you're
not not so much with the enemy types
enemy but with the civilian types for
sure I mean I mean obviously and you'd
see guys would go completely out of
their way to try and protect the
civilian the enemy over there is a lot
different now yeah yeah there's there's
a there's you know here you have a
uniformed soldier yeah you know they're
you don't have a uniformed soldier
you got somebody that's trying to sneak
around and and building up with my EE D
and yeah you don't see that same level
of now I mean once you get a guy
captured that's it you know okay we got
him captured zip them up put them in the
back of the Humvee I mean that's it yeah
so you definitely what what he talks
about is this this mutual respect of
like look we're sitting in a slit trench
getting mortared and when I feel like
when I meet you you're on the other side
but I know that you've been slipped into
sitting a slit trench getting mortared
all day right that's why we have mutual
respect for each other yeah in Iraq it's
asymmetrical warfare so they're not
suffering the same type of situation and
and they also you know one thing that
that really throws that stuff out the
window is the way that the insurgents
treated to civilian populace yeah you
know so so we're witnessing non-judicial
murders like when executions we're
seeing that we're seeing civilians
getting tortured we're seeing you know
people being beheaded and so when you
see that you're they're trying to help
these people and you start to think look
V if you're another infantryman and
opposing army I can I can empathize with
you understand what you're going through
but if you're even if you're another
army but I see you raping torturing
murdering burning people alive
I don't empathize with you anymore it
doesn't work that way
so not really yeah now you would get
occasionally you'd get like you could
tell that someone would be mixed up in
something that they shouldn't have been
mixed up in maybe a young kid and maybe
a 17 18 year old because because some of
those kids some of the insurgents were
not vehement
we you know pro al Qaeda some of them
were just hey look I'm gonna get paid 50
bucks to put an IV in the road to my gig
yeah and and if you paid me 50 bucks to
go and plant you know crop over there I
just assume do that yeah
so you'd see some of that there'd be
okay look this this kids just you know
he just caught up and something doesn't
understand and then again I mean all
again the dichotomy is if you're putting
an ID in the road to kill Americans
though I don't care about you and I want
to kill you that's all there is to that
in and but it's definitely a different
scenario when the people that you're
fighting are are the ones that are
committing these kinds of atrocities
because even as these guys you know they
did you see how he differentiate between
like the waffen-ss and like a normal
infantry group he differentiates those
two yeah that'd be like if let's say the
war in Iraq was against let's say
al-qaeda had taken over Iraq and you
were fighting even the hardened al-qaeda
guys or some normal you know infantrymen
Iraq your army like oh yeah those guys
you'd have been like a look this dude
surrendered okay yeah the al-qaeda guys
first of all they're probably not going
to surrender and if they do that's
they're going to not get the same
treatment that a that a guy that's a
victim of circumstance right a lot of
the Germans their victim a circumstance
a that this guy came into power I was a
soldier I'm a soldier yeah you know and
man heavy it is but there is a
definitely a mutual respect that you
have for for another servicemen that's
you know has been through the same kind
of crap that you've been through yeah
make sense
so with that speaking a heavy lifting
kettlebell anyway I feel like we should
talk about on it on it great kettlebells
again I do feel spoiled even every time
I pick them up even though they're dope
you know the artistic ones and she would
call them artistic no because they have
names right primal bells they'll just
call them that and I'm rather than or
legend bells all that stuff you know I
feel kind of spoiled because they're
kind of like the designer ones they're
designer ish balance by the way anyway
got into that um
here's the thing about the guy and I
said this before starting light with
kettlebells is critical my friend
Anthony came over you remember Anthony
no there the first day we recorded he
was at my house oh yeah yeah so he came
over the other day and he was like hey
Ellis left and you know last time I seen
him I wasn't so much into the kettlebell
so I was like alright we're doing this
thing be careful and I saw and he had I
don't think he'd ever done you hurt no
but borderline all he just he grabbed
the lightest one and you know I should
start light or whatever and you could
tell his imma say this was all due
respect if you haven't done it before it
makes sense but like his form was way
off and I'm thinking bro you're gonna
get hurt real careful yeah so I was
going to go into like what crazy workout
I did but I'll save that for another
time since we're now three hours right
now or now I just look at my watch 253
that's not a good sign so I apologize to
everyone in the world for doing a three
and a half hour podcast which is going
to turn into a fact for teen workouts a
for an F of a detail nonetheless so
we'll create krill oil real quick I was
talking to somebody at the muster think
it was I forget who it was nonetheless
was talking about the benefits yet again
it's like a common thing it's true
I don't exaggerate about the krill oil
is no kind like I can't go back to not
taking krill I don't take the krill oil
and I don't mind see Oh actually we were
talking to lace remember I said you ran
out of Rolla
yeah and he's all mad at me because you
gave me some oh yours I didn't Rosalee
yeah actually technically technically
was generally who brought me something I
think I just gave you what nonetheless
he gave me yeah so I guess he's gonna
have a part of it got the credit yep
nonetheless
I'll never go back to no krill oil so
where would you get it on it krill
what if you wanted to save money to go
on it calms last chocolate there's a lot
of things on there and on it is one of
those good companies slash website where
anything you need like anything you need
supplementation with all the way down to
workouts they got it on there try your
best not to get too addicted
you the website because very that very
really person that has that issue
I don't think so high I will guaranteed
people spend time like watching the
videos and stuff browsing the products
sometimes you can get like we talked
about the you know how you get on Amazon
and you're like yeah I want to get that
thing too you don't really need it just
looks super cool it's one of those
Amazon's Amazon does that yeah so be
careful it does but it I don't think it
like prompts you it's just the list of
stuff is all cool you know it's not just
a kettlebell it's a really cool one you
know so it's that situation anyway on a
comm flash chocolate if you want the ten
percent off and yeah report back tell me
what you think and if you ask me about
the krill oil right I'll tell you I'll
tell you till the end of time I will not
not take krill oil ever again if I have
anything to say about it another way to
support is when you pick up your copy of
a teen platoon or whichever books you
choose that chuckle reads on this
podcast go on our website jackal
podcast.com go to the book section on
the top says books from episodes click
through there the heads up if you're
looking to get a teen platoon the book
you actually you can get it on Amazon
used yeah for like 40 bucks to use a
copy which they'll all be gone
yeah by the times of whoever you are
listening to do this you can also get it
from a website rifles direct comm which
actually supports the rifles Regiment in
the UK so you can get it there as well
or you can buy the used hardcover copies
from the Amazon yeah calm after you
click through yeah click through there
bloom and you know even if you're buying
something else a click through support
the cause anyway another way subscribe
to the podcast on iTunes stitcher Google
Play and any other podcast providing
platforms also and not excluding YouTube
yeah
YouTube's a good one video version I got
YouTube red by the way ok wait wait
what's the benefits ago one of the
benefits is on you
Reb you can listen to you even if you go
to another app all right yeah so playing
so real it's a real cool deal for me
yeah I am and sounds pretty no house I
like that yeah I know you do they're
relevant most of time yeah unless you
see the same ad over and over and again
edge you know what though
you know when they play you ever see the
same well you don't see ads anymore
no but for us who may or may not enjoy
ads and or still have the only person
that in a cab you guys not all you know
you know house is it like here for
example so ty Lopez right they all have
like a head every single time I know you
know there's this other financial
company which is a weird one which is
really poorly done nonetheless it so ty
Lopez here's the example ty Lopez he'll
be like it'll talk about some stuff
and then it's the same at over note and
after a while you're like okay okay skip
the ad but then it kind of sticks with
you and then you're kind of like yeah
that's called advertising but yeah but
it's kind of like yeah I see what's
going on yet I still am compelled you
know so it's like it's kind of like it's
beneficial almost I'm over here not
compelled compelled uh no anyway I am
compelled to subscribe to YouTube yeah
yeah okay there you go
so you're trying to say you had a lot of
other stuff right now well you know age
is not healthy I go on in these tangents
and it's relevant I feel like people can
relate on some level sometimes maybe
occasionally me weird people nonetheless
YouTube that's a good one video version
what's the what's Jocko podcast is the
channel yeah dr. Roger Kast yeah sure
it'd be cool if you put videos on there
more often I do it like two three week
oh yeah two three week now kind of okay
good I'm looking forward to that new
whatever I hope I put one on the other
two what is Monday yeah okay that's one
it's it's whatever it is right now yeah
man Thursday
don't worry no worries I got you go to
subscribe to that if you haven't already
and you can get the video version and
excerpts which are shareable shareable
meaning they're just shorter and
they're shorter so you know whoever
opens it and the more of a chance
they're gonna listen to it when it's two
three minutes long rather than two and a
half three and a half in this case hours
long that's it's not fired from doing
podcasts because they're too long is
that possible
maybe I guess what else what anything is
possible right that's the thing um what
else
Jaco has a store it's called Jocko store
website chuckles door calm see catchy
right easy to remember if it's a store
and it's Jocelyn's is chocolate or if
it's a podcast and Jacques is Jocko
podcast if it's you know if it's
keychains I was meeting some jungle
keychain I was meeting some people
talking to some people at a group the
other day who were not familiar with me
or with anything disrespect a and they
they said oh well you do you know one
who said oh he's got a podcast and then
the other one said oh what's the name of
the podcast
that's what other podcast is called
Jacques a podcast and she said this one
girl said did you pay your marketing
team a lot for that that's you know
exactly real original like that yeah so
original but hey Madame you know could
be worse so back to the store
Jaakko store that is some t-shirts on
there if you want to represent you know
the t-shirts carry a message the message
has layers actually I guess technically
the shirts have layers because the
message is one of the layers of the
shirt
okay anyway go there Jeff Lester calm if
you like something get something that's
a good way to start where shirts coming
out this week that's my question to you
yeah that's the intention okay so I'm
getting angry yes understand understand
oh but you'll make me get in your
business ain't no Elfi normal fee don't
as almost my favorite isn't way normal
but don't make me come and get in your
business and do your job for you you've
ever heard me talk on this podcast I
talk about what people don't do their
job that's awesome even I can take the
job from them right right you gotta step
it down and think about what I'm more my
mindset is and you may want to step it
up over on your end
well bang you're going to do
to the song yes not another respect I am
I did it and we're going to try to get
that that's right for you know what to
do you know why you're saying this right
now because you can't wait for the shirt
that you designed to come on if you want
the recognize also I think you're I
think you might be some sabotaging and
sabotaging my efforts I made the better
shirt uh-huh and you don't want to print
it mm-hmm because you're self-conscious
uh-huh and that's not gonna stand well I
will give you the respect because there
is in fact layers to this shirt as well
so all right how about this more layers
more layers you all Yelly yeah you could
be right I think you might have more
layers than the standard I guess we'll
see we're gonna find out about that one
anyway shuffle start off the women's
stuff on there as well some patches some
rash guards some cool rash guards you
know indeed put these other stuff anyway
one there check it out if you want
something to get something good way to
support also psychological warfare
if you're having trouble if you're
having trouble if you're like me and
sometimes used to or currently having
trouble with not feeling like working
out not feeling like it so you're
considering skipping the work out
waiting for tomorrow making your workout
day into a rest day if you're having
that problem this is what you did go
psychological warfare search on itunes
google boy amazon amazon obviously
anyway where you can get mp3s
you search psychological warfare Jaakko
a link and it's an album with track and
the news tracks will help you through
anything that you're feeling that
weakness like I just mentioned whether
it be waking up early or skipping the
workout or cheating on the diet and I
say cheating on the diet because you
made a promise to yourself you're not
gonna eat those donuts you made a
promise and then now like all of a
sudden eat the doughnuts no that's not
the problems you may just think I can
never eat a doughnut again no sure
exactly right you can't because everyone
in the world will like some little there
with a with a camera yeah I know give me
good yeah yeah
f'hace and consider this like what if
you knew hundred-percent no one's you
know watch you know whatever then you're
eating the donut can you imagine the
guilt you're feeling yeah I'm good
guilt yeah you can do it you're done
donut so much guilt no but in the event
of other people not you draw for other
people feeling that weakness there's a
track for that remember back when iPhone
kind of came out and there's that thing
there's an app for that remember they
used to always say that oh there's an
app so that is it out for that that was
like an expression okay look it with
this there's a track for that seems I
just made that up right now
anyway psychological warfare you check
it if you need that that spot because
really that's what it is it's a spot in
life when you try to lift heavy things
it's good to have a spot if you're
lifting light stuff or not lifting at
all you don't need a spot so don't even
worry about that if you're not doing
nothing don't even get this you don't
even need it if you're not doing
anything in life don't get it jimson
yeah get it - exactly
all right like I said 18 platoon you can
get that at rifles direct comm from the
UK it supports that regiment which I'm
all about also you know speaking of rash
guards and stuff check out origin main
comm my boy up there Pete Roberts he's
kind of he's kind of a psycho actually
he heard I'm a madman he's all about
manufacturing in America which I'm all
about - and I'm gonna go into this but
at some point but like he wanted to make
keys here and he couldn't get the fabric
so he went out and bought old abandoned
looms from abandoned factories and hired
like old timers that knew how to work
these things and refurbish them and
rebuilt them and has made these looms
brought them back to life so he can make
keys and rash guards here in America in
Maine and like I said that's kind of
crazy
borderline psychopathic which I kind of
like and yeah that's kind of why we're
kind of working on joining forces in
some way Pete origin warpath it's going
down we're going to make something
happen I'll keep everyone in
formed as we finalize the plan that rash
guard that you mentioned yeah
and posted the video oh yeah that was a
lot nicer is a lot oh yeah I'm certain
legit then I and yeah when you see it it
underplayed it you look at well you
didn't have it I made it sound like just
kind of cheesy yeah like you but you
didn't realize it was that bad yeah but
the thing is that rash guard it's
already sold out no so now he's printing
a bunch more but there but he got away
you gotta weave the material yeah yeah
right or gets he gets one of his
producers here in America with some
materials so anyways check out that
origin main comm growing company we're
getting in league with them
big-time also jock a white tee on Amazon
here's a here's an actual again this is
a certified verified report I have a cat
that used to catch one or two mice per
month I forgot to pick up a tea bag
after I brewed it and the cat ate the
tea bag now my cat is bringing home
raccoons full-grown rabbits and even the
neighbor's dog so be careful don't let
your cat get it unless your neighbor's
dog is going to go I know the chocolate
cake you can have it and it's not
doesn't take it the thing is doesn't
taste like normal tea it tastes like
victory
alright way the warrior kid boom also
this is a warning about window or your
kid when you order way of the warrior
kid just go ahead and also order a
pull-up bar some flashcards some healthy
food energy Jitsu G because when your
kid gets done reading this factually
they're going to want to be stronger
better tougher and smarter so supply
them the way they need to be supplied
quit playing around
get some also the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual there's no book
like this doesn't exist it is not a
normal book it's kind of like the
podcast this podcast is not for everyone
not everyone wants to listen this
podcast
that's okay I'm not making a podcast for
everyone we're making a podcast for
people that like to get after it so this
book is not for people that want to read
um junk sure some people don't get the
podcast some people aren't gonna
understand the book they're knocking on
know where it's coming from
that's okay I'm not I'm not I'm not
we're not toning down the podcast right
now we're not saying I'll you know what
I think everyone would like it more if
we did more you know interspersed some
some jokes throughout it and maybe if we
made it 45 minutes and do a little fun
presentation if I get some backup music
just to kind of a little jangle to make
people get in the spirit we're not doing
that not happening yeah if you want to
listen to a little Django or a little
you know metallic risk to get you in the
zone on the beginning of the podcast
that's cool but if you want that that's
awesome there's other podcasts that
offer it we don't offer it here you know
what you're going to get with the book
if you're looking for a you know 50
shades of gray you're not going to get
that it's but that's the cool thing the
cool thing is that the publisher let me
do whatever I wanted to do so I did and
I made give a feel you're going to feel
that that's that the feeling of the
podcast mm-hmm is the same feeling that
the book get you day so it's a little
heavy mm-hmm little dark right sparse
right get after it that's in there
anyways this one equals for you freedom
Field Manual order it it's it's not
printed I'll give you a living example
it's not printed on white paper go
straight up let's just go from there
it's actually printed the background is
all images thanks black and white images
I know that comes as a big surprise to
everyone and then put over that is words
so there you go little indicator of what
the field manuals like you can get that
you preorder it now of course extreme
ownership it's a little book it's about
leadership it's actually it's about
combat leadership and how you can take
the combat leadership principles that we
don't on the battlefield and apply them
to your life you can get that book
through if you want it we also have a
tional on front consulting me Lafe
babban JP janelle Dave Burke we will
come and help your team
align your leadership so you can crush
your enemies you just heard Sydney Gerry
saying it a leadership is the thing that
makes you overcome seemingly impossible
things so if your leadership isn't
squared away
you're not going to overcome them so you
need to get in the game you can contact
us info at national on front comm if you
want that also the muster we just got
back from the Austin muster outstanding
outstanding it was awesome so many great
people there lessons learned knowledge
spread Tim Kennedy was there Tim Kennedy
showed up and it was cool and I didn't
realize it until we were at jujitsu and
I think I came up to you instead that
Stern jujitsu so the last night we have
Thursday then Friday and the Friday
night we don't do jujitsu we went to
10th planet at Austin Austin 10th planet
Jiu Jitsu with my boy Curtis Curtis Todd
wait Lisa and Todd white representing
who represent yeah he's an old-school
like me and him or from that same era
yeah we're from the same era from back
in the day only here only he's a better
artist a better artist with me yeah so
when we went and and what I realized is
this you know like way the warrior kid
people say ah man I wish I had that book
when I was a kid is an extreme ownership
people say oh man I was sad that I was
had that book when I started out my you
know when I got promoted five years ago
and you know what I say about way the
warrior kid I wish I had it when I was a
kid you don't I say about extremely
ownership I
I had it when I was a vote assistant
platoon commander I wish I had it yeah I
didn't have it and what's cool about the
muster is so that feeling when you go to
mustard you're giving just like we're
just giving this massive amount of
information pragmatic information that
you can take and you can execute with
yeah and so when we were at jujitsu I
realized man we just all this at these
people in this room just got all this
information and it and it's so practical
that you can take back your team and
then on top of all that here's a little
something else jiu-jitsu
yeah because um only 1/4 of the people
that came to jiu-jitsu had ever trained
existed before the other what was a 50
people that had never trained before so
they're getting this gift yeah the gift
of jiu-jitsu a little intro yeah yeah
man little intro now I would say 50% of
them will go back and start training
yeah maybe more I wish it was a hundred
percent yeah it might be it might be
yeah it did be a dependable you're into
you yeah yeah it's hard
it was always bizarre to me that when I
introduced someone is easy to it was a
100% conversion rate you know it'd be a
100 percent conversion rate yeah 100% oh
you just chokes me and I couldn't stop
you I need to learn that 100% otherwise
I go through life vulnerable to being
choked by anyone I don't like that
feeling
ya know I don't like this the muster to
is sprinkled and I don't and I mean
heart sprinkles hard by the way which is
a very critical compelling part in my
opinion is this the social stuff and I
don't mean social like you're just
cruising and not learning I mean the
people you need oh yeah well you
definitely are going to meet good people
there yeah because everyone there is in
the game big-time and they're all
looking to get better they're all
invested to get better yes and any other
thing is you know we're hanging out I
got ya know there's me Lafe Dave JP echo
or not there's no green room it doesn't
exist we don't even take breaks just
like felt really good when when we take
a break to let the audience like go to
the restroom or grab a you know a cup of
coffee or a jock a white tee we we just
read
stand there like we stepped down office
agent we get everyone lines up when we
talk questions and you know what I was
doing this time was I was like instead
of answering one person's question just
to that person I was in here from career
could he's asking for anyone coming
where's your bike hey what is this
there's 12 people standing in line yeah
instead of answering this one question
this one guy whispering no hey everyone
come up here Malaya and you can all hear
this because once the who knows maybe
there's some of those questions maybe
something experienced in the future I
don't know yeah you might as well listen
and maybe you have a better solution
than I have yeah it's like a like a
little brain on table yeah briam yeah
yeah it's cool that that's true you
we take breaks every what we're there's
breaks throughout the thing you take
yeah Jacquelyn don't take another x-ray
cuz break time is talk times off you
guys oh yeah in jail yeah sign a book
whatever yeah no green room no green
room itself that's the master and by the
way they've sold out all of them that
we've done have been sold out now the
next one that we got coming up is
September 14th and 15th back the Omni
Hotel in downtown San Diego California
muster zero force it's gonna sell out
this is a known fact so if you want to
come it's September 14th and 15th that
is right around the corner so if you
want to come to that come to that
extreme ownership calm is where you can
register if you want to also by the way
this is interesting if you train
jiu-jitsu or if you're interested in
training jiu-jitsu origin up in Maine
has this immersion camp that they do I'm
going Echo's going with me
we're going up there it is there's two
sessions that they run it's the 20th
august 22-23 or august 24th and the 27th
those are the two different sessions or
you can come to the whole week anyways
I'm going to be there for those middle
three days like Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so I'm going to be there for
the last day of the first camp and the
first day of the lot of the second camp
and I'll be on there on the middle day
we're gonna be training
rolling talking hanging out eating
lobster eating steaks
uh just generally getting after it so
you go to orange name.com if you want to
come up there's not a lot of spaces for
that it's it's it's not that's like I
think the most they're going to go is
200 people so that's not a lot of spaces
so if you want to come up register quick
panel see you guys up there in Maine I'm
gonna what I like about it is unlike the
muster where everything is scheduled
like we don't have a lot of break time
and even the break times were working
this thing I mean you can only train
jiu-jitsu what six hours a day maybe
okay you know what I mean two hours in
the morning two hours at launch two
hours in the evening so that's six hours
you know you're going to sleep four
hours so you still got 14 hours left in
the day so what are we going to do we're
going to kick it yeah we're going to
cruise there's a lake there's kayaks
there's a zip lines in whatever yeah
I'll just go lay in bed and try and
recover did you do session uh so yeah um
bunch of good people coming up after
that if you want to come up and hang out
do it then that will work we'll see you
up there you go at the muster or we'll
see you at the immersion she can't leave
how do you register for that one origin
main calm and then you click on the
immersion thing and you'll find it you
press Google figure it out yeah yeah
there's a certain element of like if you
can't figure it out don't bother yeah
and there's also a certain element of
like hey register now I can go to this
thing oh yeah today
register today you're the only thing
today yeah I know they say that today by
the time this podcast comes out it won't
even be today so alright also until
we're at one of those events if you want
to roll with us virtually we are on the
interwebs the Twitter the Instagram
[Music]
the Facebook Keep Watch echo is that
echo Charles and I am at Jocko will Inc
and finally thank you to everyone for
listening to this podcast and for
supporting this podcast which by the way
is made possible by our military who
protects our great nation from evil this
podcast is made possible by police law
enforcement firefighters EMTs first
responders that keep us safe and orderly
here at home and it's made possible by
each and every one of you out there
working in the economy making and
creating and building so don't stop
doing that and don't ever stop
remembering those that went before us
those that still shine down on us and
remember that we are not here long and
time is fleeting it is ever fleeting so
you might as well make it a good hard
run then get after it so until next time
this is echo and Jocko out